Film Courage: The question is what's required to sell
your script in the current marketplace?
The last time we visited with you Cory you
talked to us about this 'six script
cycles' and having pitch-perfect
authentic scripts. Have things changed?
Corey Mandell, Instructor/Screenwriter: Things have just gotten better and to
really put things in perspective I
started teaching right during the
writers strike to 2007 and especially
after the writers strike it was bleak
there were writers with impressive
credits who couldn't get work it was
nearly impossible to sell a script all
the TV was almost all reality TV there
was very little scripted Studios were
all finalizing their consolidation and
they just weren't making movies back
then it was like if a good month was one
or two of my students selling a pitch or
an original script that was a good month
in the last week I've had 21 students
all pitches or pilot scripts that's a
pretty normal week so to put this in
perspective around 2002 HBO their entire
budget all-in for original content was
about five hundred five hundred million
dollars which is a lot of money this
year Netflix will be spending about
fifteen to sixteen billion dollars
amazon's about six billion dollars those
just netflix and amazon are spending
twenty one twenty two billion dollars
and everyone else is trying to catch up
to them there's never been so much
content sold there's never been such an
insatiable demand for original material
now that said while it's far easier to
sell a script than it used to it's still
not easy it's never easy to sell an
original script especially for an
unknown writer who doesn't have a track
record it's easier but it's not
necessarily easy but there are things
that people can do to give themselves a
much better chance so one of them is
that definitely understand how to
properly set up and launch an engine in
the pilot so a pilot script does not
have a proper engine it's a pilot it's
not a TV show an engine is what is going
to propel the drama or the comedy it's
what's going to organically propel the
content for many many episodes ideally
many many seasons and whenever I bring
in executives and producers to my you
la Casas they'll say like one of the
biggest ways you can tell an amateur is
they don't have a proper engine built
into the pilot so that's one thing
that's absolutely critical and probably
only 20% of writers are doing that so
80% of writers they might have the most
amazing characters and world and story
but without that engine it's not a TV
show it's just a one-off script I'm
going to put out a bunch of content on
engine so if anyone's interested they
can email my assistant Lisa at Corey
Mandel net and she can get you that
information so let's say you have an
engine then obviously you need amazing
characters and an amazing story there
are a lot of writers who are really
strong on one side of that but weaker on
the other so their writers who can
create really compelling characters that
we love and we want to spend time with
but their stories somehow just they're
not where they need to be there's other
writers who can come up with really
strong stories with great twists and
great escalations but their characters
either all have the same voice or just
somehow they're just not authentically
compelling enough to really pull us in
and want to spend time with them which
is critical for a TV show the absolute
essential way to overcome that is a
training process of creative integration
and I talked about that a couple years
ago it film curse so you can go back and
check out that video it's called
creative integration and if you haven't
seen it I'd actually highly suggest you
give that a look so let's say you have a
really strong engine let's say you have
great characters you have great story
the next thing you want to be making
sure is that you're nailing the genre
and a lot of writers will fall a little
short here so if it's a comedy we are we
need to be laughing out loud multiple
times I know many agents that say if I
don't laugh out loud at least six times
when I read your script I'm not signing
you if you're a comedy writer I worked
with a couple writers recently who wrote
horror scripts horror pilot scripts and
so what I challenge them is to write the
script in such a way that if someone's
reading the script alone especially at
night they're gonna stop and they're
gonna go to their boyfriends or their
girlfriends or a coffee shop because
they don't want to read this script all
because it's scaring the bejesus out of
them and they really embrace that and
that's that's absolutely what they went
for and both those scripts ended up
selling if you're writing a police
procedural a homicide detective trying
to solve a murder when we read your
script we should feel like you were a
homicide detective in so much as like
really feeling like this is someone who
really knows they've been there this
feels real that doesn't mean that you
have to have been a homicide detective
but it means you need to have done your
research and know how to develop
characters in such a way that when we
read your script it at least feels like
you were a homicide detective so there
are a lot of writers who are funny or
dramatic or horrific and they're they're
really good at the genre but they're not
amazing so you really want to make sure
you can go that extra mile so having a
really strong engine is absolutely
required in the marketplace compelling
characters in story and nailing the
genre but the one thing that is probably
most important is the concept especially
if you're a newer writer and having high
impact concept or high concept where in
one or two or three lines the
marketplace producers or executives are
thinking there's something unique here
and this is a great idea for a TV show
and so having that concept is absolutely
essential and what writers really want
to focus on is proof of concept and so
let me tell you a true story so there is
a manager I love her she has one of the
best track records of developing new
writers and launching their careers so
this is what she does so imagine you
just got signed by this manager so what
she says is be home tonight at eleven
o'clock so you just got signed by this
manager you're excited 11 o'clock you're
at home like okay what's and there's a
knock on the door you open it up there's
a messenger or a courier with a box you
have to sign for it and you put the Box
down and you open it up and what's
inside 20 scripts and there's a note
from the manager says read all these
scripts be prepared to discuss
particularly the concepts tomorrow
morning 8:30 my office okay so now it's
11:08 you've got 20 scripts you start
reading now the reason she does this is
imagine it's 2:00 2:30 in the morning
you've read most of the scripts you're
boned tired you've got three scripts
left you grab one of them you start
reading the characters are great the
dialogue is great it's making you laugh
you get through five pages seven pages
you don't know what the concept is you
get through ten pages you get through
twelve pages you don't know what the
concept for the show is you get really
frustrated you start to really hate that
writer and at some point you just start
skimming trying to figure out the
concept and you're just so
overwhelmingly exhausted and frustrated
when the writer shows up to the manager
the next morning the manager doesn't
want to talk about any of the scripts
what she wanted the writer to do is have
that experience because that's the
experience that the development
executive or the producer has they're
going home on Friday with the pile of
scripts and especially if you're an
unknown writer who hasn't proven
yourself if they start reading your
script if they don't know what the
concept is because you have to
understand that a pilot script is a
selling document it's different what
you're actually going to see if they buy
it and make the show the script you
write it's job is to sell and the
concept is what differentiates this
project think about how much TV there is
is so overwhelming we can't watch all of
the TV so the concept really it's like
the brand it differentiates what this
project is so they want to hit that hard
and they want to hit that fast and I
know a lot of managers or agents that
will tell their especially their newer
clients by page 10 you have to nail the
concept where someone who reads the
script knows what this show what it what
the concept for the show is it has to be
there by page 10 I know a lot of
managers will say that I don't think it
actually has to be there by page 10 but
I think it wants to be there really as
fast as possible and a lot of writers
will write the pilot where it's not to
the very end of the pilot or sometimes
even the second episode until you
actually know what the concept is so
proof of concept is get that concept
across to the reader as fast as possible
and make it as compelling as possible a
lot of writers and I don't think they
realize they do this is they can pull
their punches a little bit they can get
a little nervous so there was a movie a
while ago now called Bad Santa very dark
inappropriate about the worst Santa ever
doesn't look like a mall Santa he's
drunk he's sitting on the the moms and
that's that's the team stuff I mean it
is crude and so inappropriate and if you
love Christmas and you cherish Christmas
you're gonna hate this concept but if
you're in a dark mood and you're like a
movie that just goes all in I'm making
fun of Christmas in the worst possible
way there's going to be people are gonna
be like now that's a great idea
and that writer did not pull his punches
what a lot of writers would do is say
well they're gonna be people that might
be offended let me not quite go so far
into this so that they can maybe they'll
like it but you're not trying to get the
people who aren't fans to like a little
bit more your big concern should be
there are people out there that are
going to say the idea of a guy who sells
crystal meth and sells it
who who blackmails his former students
that he flunked out to cook meth with
him this very dark train wreck of a TV
show someone out there says that is just
so amazingly interesting
that's your audience and your concern
shouldn't be that you might offend some
people your concern is that your
constituency would have bought it if
you'd gone all in if you just absolutely
commit you know when the marvelous
missus myzel was being developed
everyone in industry was saying we need
dark we need edgy no one wanted light
the marvelous miss myzel is so sweet and
it is just so beautiful and it is so not
edgy and that writer just went for it I
mean she relished in it and there were I
know people that say oh I don't watch
that show it's too sweet for me and I
know a lot of people myself included who
loved that show you know given the world
everything that's going on in the world
for me watching that show is like a
delicious piece of dessert at the end of
the day so whatever your
concept is proof of concept is establish
it early and prove to us prove to the
industry prove to the marketplace that
this is a great concept so if you're
doing catastrophe and you're saying look
it's two people who meet and get married
and they don't live happily ever after
it is the hell of marriage if you marry
the wrong person where every mundane
thing in life is the just insufferable
then and you're saying what's gonna make
this compelling is that people are gonna
love these two characters and this dark
comedy then you've got an ale that dark
comedy real early on to prove to us that
this is a TV show
I mean imagine that the the people who
were developing Seinfeld to show about
nothing it's these very immature
narcissistic characters that make
mountains out of mole hills but nothing
happens no one learns a lesson nothing
changes it's what life is really like
it's a sitcom based on reality I can see
a lot of writers going a show about
nothing I better make it Lisa in the
pilot about a little something because
they would be nervous so go all in on
your concept and establish it as early
as possible that's proof of concept I
know a lot of managers who will bring in
their writers and they'll say where does
the concept launch where in this script
is it clear what the concept for this
show is and the writer says page 12
they'll take the first 12 pages the
first 12 pages rip it out of the script
and all they'll do is read those 12
pages and at the end they're like how
much do I understand and how excited I
am about this concept and they'll share
it around the office to other people
because if people are not all in on this
concept they're not going to keep
reading so it doesn't really matter the
rest of the script now that said let's
say you have a great concept and you
nailed it early and when people get
there they're like or at least your
constituency the people who would love
that concept or like yeah that's a great
concept for a show you're gonna need to
have an engine the characters in the
story need to unfold I'm not saying all
that stuff isn't important I'm just
saying
really focus on your concept really go
all-in do not pull your punches and
especially as a new writer nail it early
earlier than you want to so that the the
marketplace can quickly know here's the
concept for the show and if it's not a
concept they're interested in they won't
keep reading they won't waste their time
because it's not for them if it is a
concept they're interested in they're
going to be Wow then they'll read the
rest of the script to see if you have
all those other pieces and just the last
thing I'll say is you know there are
writers your idea machines they just
come up with so many really great
concepts there are other writers that
really struggle to come up with high
concepts there are specific training
there are specific tools that people can
use to come up with more and more high
concepts and again I would direct you to
my assistant Lisa at Corey Mandel net
and she could definitely provide you
some more information on that front
can we give an example of a concept
versus an engine with one of these shows
whether it's Breaking Bad, Mr. Robot
Marvelous Mrs. Masial the problem is that
an engine would take probably 30 minutes
to break down what an engine is and how
it works so we wouldn't have time to do
that I mean I can talk about concepts
but to contrast it to an engine I guess
I'm just struggling with it seems to me
that the concept is the engine but maybe
I'm missing something
so so just trying to figure out you know
with Breaking Bad right we get what the
concept is guys sort of had just wit's
end
financially and health-wise he needs to
turn things around he's willing to make
sort of this deal with the devil
but then what is the engine the engine
is you're introducing these different
characters yes so unfortunately that's
why I was sending people to the site
because it's it's a little bit more
complex what an engine is it's hard to
do that quickly I mean that the metaphor
would be so I'm Breaking Bad the concept
is so we know what this show is and we
know where it's going to go
the engine is what propels the show
there and that is there's a sister
there's a family there's just no oh no
it's it's trickier than it's okay okay
okay yeah just trying to pinpoint how do
I know that I could have a great concept
but how do I know this metaphorical
engine is working and it's not like a
crap engine and it's gonna just sputter
out it and so that's why I'm just trying
to figure out what yeah and I'm I'm
happy to send you some video content and
if you're really I'm happy to do that to
you
personally but in terms of now is it's
it would be beyond beyond the scope okay
okay but the but concept and engine are
two different things
yes two different okay yes okay thank
you why is it important for
screenwriters to know about selling
their screenplay before they sit down
and write their screenplay yeah that's a
really smart and a really great question
so part of it is again that as much as
we would love this scenario that someone
would read our pilot script and say yes
and write a check and make it that just
almost never happens the best-case
scenario is someone reads the script and
then they're going to meet with you and
they're gonna want to ask you questions
and they want it the script is proving
the concept it's proving the characters
that you know how to write characters
and these are really compelling
characters and that it's a compelling
world and there's an engine so they know
this thing has potential but they're
gonna really want to know about the
first year because every production
company has had an experience early on a
buying a pilot script that they loved
and then when they tried to develop it
it just it can't no one can figure out
how to get a season or multiple seasons
of the show
so in the past several years I know very
few writers including highly established
writers who haven't gone through the
following experience that with a pitch
or a spec script they'll end up a room
with multiple executives and they're
gonna ask a lot of questions about the
first season they're gonna want to know
what are we watching in the first season
so we don't want to make sure that there
is a compelling first season now some
executives are gonna want to see a
breakdown of every episode other
executives are just gonna want to see
some big arcs other executives just
gonna want to get a big high-level
picture to know that there's a first
season and they really want to know
what's the main thing we're going to be
watching so in the marvelous miss are
mrs. myzel there's several things we're
watching over the first season but the
main thing that we're watching is the
Marvelous Mrs. Maisel going from being a
housewife who's very you know very kind
of a very private person to becoming a
stand-up comic putting the work to be a
stand-up comic that's the main thing not
the only thing the main thing we're
gonna be watching in the first season in
fleabags season two the main thing we're
gonna be watching is Fleabag
relentlessly pursuing having sex with
this priest how things are going on in
there but that's the main through lot
they want to know if the main
through-line and the main thing that
they're that they're gonna be watching
and the reason you want to figure that
out
before you write your pilot is twofold
first of all so after you write your
pilot when you get pulled in to these
meetings you have a really smart answer
but secondly remember your pilot
launches the first season so if the
first season is fleabag pursuing this
priest or missus myzel doing the work to
become a stand-up comic that needs to be
launched in the pilot so by the time
we're done with the pilot episode
fleabag is pursuing that priest and we
know why she's doing it and we are
absolutely enthralled with seeing how
that plays out
and at the end of the pilot episode of
the Marvelous Mrs. Maisel were like oh
the last woman in the world who would
ever do stand-up comedy a woman who's
just terrified and lives her life where
she can never be rejected she's the
perfect wife she's the perfect daughter
she's the perfect friend so no one would
ever reject her she's gonna try to be a
stand-up comic in the 1950s when women
aren't allowed to be stand-up comics
especially the way that she wants to do
it which is the Lenny Bruce style so at
the end of that we have to be in love
with seen her on stage and going that's
I want to go on that journey so if you
don't know your first season and you
don't know how you're gonna sell it you
don't know how to do a pilot people will
come to me for a consultation and so
I'll read their pilot and I'll start
asking them about the first year they
can't answer me that would be like going
to someone and saying I wrote the first
scene of a feature script will you read
it
is that the right first scene for my
feature and you say well I don't know
what is your feature where does it go
and they say oh I don't know I just got
the first scene that that is why pilots
are so tricky there are a lot of writers
who can write on shows that have been
structured and they're amazing but they
can't create a successful pilot a pilot
works on double dimension so first of
all the pilot episode has to pull in
strangers make them absolutely want to
keep reading relentlessly make us want
to keep reading then deliver us to an
ending that exceeds their expectations a
beginning a middle and a self-contained
story
additionally the pilot is the beginning
of a larger story which is season 1
season 1 is the beginning of the series
but let's just talk about season 1 so a
pilot launches the first season so if
you don't know the first season if you
don't know the engine you don't know the
concept and you don't know how you're
gonna sell this in the room then you
don't know how you don't know what the
right pilot episode is because the pilot
episode is not the first thing we're
going to be watching necessarily on the
show it is a selling document to get
people excited to want to meet with you
you write the pilot so you can pitch the
show you write the pilot to prove the
concept and the characters and the world
and the story and then you pitch the
show so it's absolutely essential in TV
that people understand how they're
selling the show where it's going to be
positioned the engine the concept what's
going to happen in the first year
because that will lead them to know the
right way to design and execute on their
pilot so I'm thinking of like let's say
Judd Apatow This Is 40 which was just
hilarious
if I were to then pitch that and then
it's a masterpiece for that two hours
whatever it was but then I don't know
where there's gonna be continuations
yeah of that story I don't know what
what's gonna keep happening over and
over again same thing with like let's
say Meet the Fockers I know there's been
what three films about that like Little
Fockers and the hilarious again but how
am I
turn that you know how many Christmas
dinners can I have where something goes
wrong over and over and over again so
it's got to be something where there's
going to be and I guess that's where the
engine comes into play yeah but there's
gonna be like a continuous so somebody
going to do stand-up night after night
and 50s when they could be shut down by
law enforcement or whatever that there's
gonna be incidents over and over and
over again to test that show whereas a
Christmas dinner a family birthday party
that's hilarious but it just goes wrong
do I need to have something right and
you mentioned Judd Apatow so Judd Apatow
or Vince Gilligan or gingy Cohen come in
and they have a pilot they probably
already have the show of figure it out
but if they didn't much more likely that
someone will say you'll figure it out
well we'll take that we'll we'll take
that ride with you but if you're not yet
have that track record it's ridiculous
to think that someone's gonna invest the
money and go on that ride with you so
again it's so important and and I don't
know I have a lot of students or former
students who sell a lot of original
material and they always start figuring
out the season one and then back into
the pilot okay so I figure out your
screenplay then figure out how to open
it Oh interesting establish who those
characters are their personality and
where it's going and what makes it
interesting so that that's what the pipe
the pilot has to really prove that this
has somewhere to go and it's going to be
really interesting to people and going
from a pilot to a season is it's not
impossible but it's a much lower
probability harder way to do it
right so with marvelous misses myzel
just knowing all of the characters that
are her in stand-up comedy world and and
clubs and a frequenting and all you know
all the hecklers and things so there's
so many opportunities to back that
character in to an interesting that's
certainly part of it right right where
is a family dinner and you know somebody
insults an in-law that can only go so
far kind of thing that that's it that's
it as a full TV show sure yeah yeah and
that's different soon a feature in a TV
show
God okay how to properly test your
script the absolute importance of script
testing what is script testing
script script testing so when I was
starting out a manager did this for me
and I'll forever be grateful so the way
it works is most people they'll write a
script and they'll give it to the
friends the writing group people they
trust and they want feedback you know
what's working what's not working
fatigue suggestions way to improve it
and what I was taught and I see a lot of
the more success writers working that
way working this way is they don't start
there
what they start with is script testing
and what script testing is is the first
thing is you realize that when you write
a script do you experience a movie you
experience characters and when someone
reads your script a movie plays in their
head and they experience a story and
they experience characters now a lot of
people make the assumption that the
movie that plays in my head is really
similar the movie that plays in your
head script testing is strategically
asking a series of questions to find out
what movie is playing in someone else's
head what story are they watching what's
happening why is it happening why is it
interesting or not interesting who are
the characters what a how are they
experiencing the characters how would
they describe the characters are they
engaged with the characters or they not
engage with the characters and it's
literally be able to track what they're
experiencing story and character wise as
they move through your script and what
script testing aims for is not to know
if someone likes your script loves it
hates it
suggestions critique not at first the
first is are they experiencing what I'm
experiencing and if they're not why not
what are they experiencing different
from me so when I first started teaching
at UCLA I did a I had everyone bring in
seven copies of their scribe and so
let's say you and I would switch scripts
I'd give you seven copies of my script
you'd give me seven copies of your
script you would take my seven copies
and go to seven of your friends and say
hey will you read a script by someone in
my class I haven't read it and you don't
have to have anything smart to say you
don't forget feedback you just have to
answer question
about what you experienced when you read
the script and you really make it clear
that you're not testing their reading
comprehension it's testing the writers
ability to have it come off the page and
so let's say seven of your friends say
okay I'll do that so they read my script
and then I would armed you with a series
of questions that you would ask those
writers and you would record the the
conversation and it's really important
that you haven't read the script because
you'll ask the question about the story
or the character and one of your friends
would start to give an answer and then
say is that right and you would say I
don't know I didn't read the script and
so at some point they'll just relax and
they'll just tell you what they
experienced and you record that
all seven of your friends and then you'd
come back to class and give me the
recordings and I would do the same for
you and then I would have each writer
transcribe the recordings because you
really have to hear it if you transcribe
it I have to admit when I first started
teaching at UCLA there were things I did
that were successful there were things
that there was a lot of trial and error
when I first started teaching this was a
real mixed bag because people were so
demoralized to have a script they poured
heart and soul into characters they
loved more than anything and this is
their character but everyone else was
seeing this and this is like no this is
despicable and this was an amazing
character and a lot of people will come
up to me and they're like you know be
careful of Julie in the class because I
think there's something wrong with Julie
because Julie's friends are like all
schizophrenic I'm telling you because
look at the feedback her friends are so
there was that there was one person who
just dropped out of an MFA program she
did come back oh and then I have another
woman threaten to kill herself she
didn't but that's when I stopped doing
this exercise mandatory and I would make
it you know voluntary yeah she did not
kill herself a lot of people came out of
that class went on to be working writers
and they said that this experience was
the most painful experience they had as
a writer but the most valuable because
they didn't realize that not everything
that they were putting on the page was
fully
I mean off the page to other people and
there are so many people that write
scripts that get rejected in the
marketplace or they don't get an agent
to represent them or a manager and they
feel like okay my characters or story
something's not strong enough that might
be true and it might not be true it
might be that if people actually fully
experience your characters and your
story they would have fallen in love
with it but they didn't here's a true
story now this is not a rep this is not
an average representation because this
is a little clean and easy it's not
usually this clean and easy but it'll
it'll illustrate a point so an agent
sent me a writer I about not quite a
year ago close to a year ago and is a
really talented writer who's staffed on
some really prestigious shows but had
never been able to sell original content
always her stuff was great but it just
wasn't great enough so the the manager
had soft had soft shown as shown the
script to some people in the industry
that he trusted to sort of unofficially
get feedback on it and people love
there's two main characters they love
this character they love the concept
they love the engine they loved were
this good but the second main character
found annoying just honestly like if
this character wasn't in this story I
would really be interested in this but
this character has ruined it for me and
that was hard for the writer to hear
because this character was the main
character as far as she was concerned
and it was sort of reflection it was
sort of an autobiographical II
emotionally based character to her so
that always hurts because then they're
not just rejecting your writing it feels
like they're rejecting you so what I do
when I work with a writer is a set of
reading their script and giving them my
opinions I always start with what I
won't know the movie that plays in their
head I want to know how they experience
the story and the characters to see
where it's not coming off the page the
way they see it and I knew because she
shared with me that this character was
the main issue so I started with this
character and I just asked her a series
of questions describe the character Jen
and then whoever she said I said well
why is the character this way and why
does why is the character this way and
what is the character love more than
anything in the world and why is that
and what do they fear more than anything
the role and why is that and when this
happened in the script why did the
character do it and why do you find that
so compelling and when the character did
this why did it and so it was it was a
good 30 to 40 minutes and when we were
done I could I could identify two pieces
of essential context let me just stop
and define how I would define essential
context I would define essential context
as everything the audience reader or
viewer everything the audience needs to
know or experience to understand what's
happening why it's happening and why
they should care and that's true for the
story and for the character and I was
able to identify two pieces of essential
context that were not in the script
there was something about the characters
motivation for the main thing they were
trying to achieve that it wasn't clear
to a reader and there was also something
about the characters backstory that I
think was really important
the writer kept talking about this as
part of why she cared so much about the
character and it wasn't clear in the
script and at first the writer is like
well of course it's clear and then I
would ask them to highlight where it's
clear and then in doing that the writer
was able to realize oh it's it's implied
but I could see how now someone may not
get that and then the other piece of
essential context was gone I mean it I'm
sorry in an original draft that was
there but as she rewrote it and rewrote
it it somehow got removed this is a
really common experience and just wasn't
there and she didn't catch that
because when she reads her script the
movie that and the characters that play
in her head she knows all of this she
loves these characters he knows exactly
this character is her so of course she
knows exactly why the character is doing
it now again this punch line is is
really clean and simple it's not usually
this clean and simple but with this
particular writer and again three or
four very senior people in the industry
at production companies had read this
forever
and said really like this really love
this but this character ruins it for me
okay
we just went it well she just went in
and she changed one line of dialogue to
make something crystal clear and then
she added a scene it was about a two
page scene to get that essential context
across in the script so one change one
line of dialogue and added a new scene
that was about two pages and the purpose
of this pay these two pages was to make
this critical missing essential context
clear her in her backstory yes okay
sorry I'm actually that it was her
motivation it was the lion dialogue for
her backstory but yeah so both both what
the two things that she knew that we
didn't know her experience were remedied
with a change of dialogue and adding a
two page scene Sena to her manager sent
it to actually a few of the people she
sent it to some of the people had
already seen it and he sent some new
people and everybody loved this
character and so this is this is one of
my all-time favorite characters and
there was actually multiple there were
multiple bids for that script now it's
unfortunately not usually as such that
after you do script testing you realize
I change one line a dialogue and it just
add this one little scene and the script
goes from a pass to multiple bids but
that can be the case usually there's
more there's more missing essential
context so it's a little messier than
this so it's usually multiple things
they're going to have to be addressed
and that's the whole key to script
testing is to figure out where people
are not experiencing what you're
intending and why and it almost always
comes to essential context and then it's
figuring out how to rewrite the script
so here's a true story that the writers
have publicly talked about the writers
of of Game of Thrones so a lot of people
probably know this maybe some people
don't they originally shot that pilot
and then decided to redo the whole thing
because they didn't like some of the
casting and so they literally reshot the
pilot which gave the showrunner is the
Opera
to screen the original pilot for people
and they screen it for some friends and
they realize there was a missing piece
of essential context so people who watch
the original episode the original pilot
that never aired when they got to the
end they knew that the Circe the Queen
was having an affair with Jamie who was
like her main body card there's a
there's a term for what he was like the
the head of the Queen's Guard there's an
official term and that they were having
inappropriate relations because the
Queen's married to the king but people
didn't know that that was her brother
and that whole season doesn't
necessarily work in the same way without
knowing that because that's the stakes
of the show the stakes of the show is
that Cersei will go to any lengths to
make sure that nobody knows her children
are illegitimate in that way and
illegitimate heirs to the throne so they
taught that and then of course when they
went to redo the pilot they could
rewrite and reshoot that so I this is
what I was told
only an idiot this is wasn't me talking
this was the manager talking to me only
an idiot would take a script out to the
marketplace that they haven't properly
tested to see if you have to rewrite
redesign reshoot and testing again is
making sure that is our strangers who
don't know what you're going for when
they read your script they experience a
story you experience do they experience
the characters you experience if so then
you certainly want to know what you
think you have suggestions you have
critiques you know word that it hold
your interest like you want to know all
that stuff after you know that people
are experiencing what you're
experiencing in the workshop that I
teach I just came from last night we did
an exercise where they literally wrote a
three to four page story so like a scene
but not a scene in a script like like a
short film three to four pages as an as
a exercise and they have a main
character who's trying to achieve
something and they have reasons
very motivated by the you know stakes to
achieve it and there's another character
of poses and they have really strong
reasons why they oppose three to four
pages and then everyone tested their
three to four pages to see if everyone
could fully see and experience all the
essential context and with two
exceptions everyone discovered that
there was at least one piece of
essential context that wasn't being
clear in a three to four page
the two people who nailed it are both
working writers I mean one's an
executive producer one's a staff writer
on a really successful show so they've
been trained that way so it was it is so
important to test your scripts and if
anyone wants the questions very easy go
to my website Cory Mendel net and just
sign up for the newsletter and the
autoresponder will give you the
questions so I highly recommend after
you poured heart and soul in your script
and you when you read it you're like
okay this is the movie or this is the TV
show that I want to create this is
exactly what I'm going for
I love it now go test it and see what
other people are experiencing because
when it does brought to the marketplace
I want it to be your characters I wanted
to be your story I want it to be the
best possible version of what you're
going for so make sure by testing with
the student that you had where she wrote
this sort of semi autobiographical story
and it seemed like the sidekick
character whatever was the likable one
and the protagonist was the one that
people are off putted by her it was too
off-putting
once she changed a few things one line
dialogue you said and a two-page scene
then people felt more empathy so would
that mean character you know it'd be
like so in real life and you meet
someone and let's say that they just rub
you the wrong way and you just for
whatever reason just don't want to spend
time with them and you just don't care
about them but then you find out that
they're really struggling because they
just lost their father to cancer a
really terrible cancer
and they're just having troubles in
there in that mourning period and let's
just say that you lost your father to
cancer you immediately feel different
about that sure you right and it just
changes your entire dynamic now imagine
that you meet this person you start to
spend time with them and you never know
that they just lost their father to
cancer you're gonna have a very
different experience with him so in this
case it her character when you really
understood why she was struggling why
she was making some poor decisions it
changed how you felt about her it
changed how you understood it and the
end people went from thinking this is a
very very self-centered character who
just treats people poorly this is a
character who's in a really bad space
and they're doing their best and they
actually are trying to protect their
friend but they're doing it in the wrong
way but it's and it just changed how
everyone felt about that god okay it
could be that subtle 90% of scripts are
rejected by the industry after the first
scene yeah so what are screenwriters
doing wrong and what well like what's so
horrible about her what's so terrible
about these scenes yeah so when I was a
studio reader so when I was in film
school with a crazy dream to be a writer
I was working as a studio reader and
what we were trained is read the first
two scenes but let me step back if a
script came in by the Coen brothers or
Quentin Tarantino or you you're reading
that whole script and if you don't like
it you're reading it again to see what's
wrong with you and then you're calling
your friends who read it like you taking
this very seriously because you giving
them extreme benefit of the doubt but I
was taught when you're reading a script
by some unknown writer a new writer read
the first two scenes and stop and ask
yourself do I have to keep reading and
if the answer's no then don't I have a
lot of students who are readers now and
they do they have the one scene I guess
you know tensions fans have shrunken
with Twitter and everything so they read
one scene I think here's what I would
say if I read a scene of a scrub
and it doesn't absolutely make me want
to read the next scene I know this
writer is not going to be successful
script why it's not gonna get better if
you if you your first scene is like your
interviews if someone goes to a job
interview for a job they really want
their late their disheveled
the reek of alcohol they're doing
inappropriate jokes they're just doing
everything wrong right you're
interviewing this person you're like
okay this is this person on their best
behavior or you know you're on a first
date as person is a disaster this is
them on their best behavior
yeah your first scene is if you know
anything about writing it's your first
impression that is you on your best
behavior oh I like that so if your first
scene it doesn't have conflict just
something I believe I talked about in a
previous film courage video otherwise
there's a lot on my site about that or
the characters don't feel like
compelling characters or it's supposed
to be funny but it's not like all the
stuff we were talking about you know in
terms of what you're selling with a
pilot script now I'm not looking for an
engine I don't need to have the concept
but it bet you better nail the genre and
and the characters better be characters
that absolutely want to spend time with
and you better know how to write in
compelling conflict now let's say
someone can do all of that that doesn't
mean that the whole script is going to
be great it means it might and you know
one of the things and by the way I
really would recommend for anyone who's
serious about being a writer if possible
try to go on the other side of the fence
for six months try to be a reader
someone who value eight scripts for six
months you can do it for that for the
like the writing competitions but if
possible especially if you live in LA I
would try to do it for an agency a
management company a production company
producer someone who's in the industry
someone was involved with buying of
projects and I always tell people do it
for six months but not a day longer
because you'll lose your soul
and I don't mean that what I mean is
most people most writers who start down
that path if they stay on that path too
long they end up becoming executives or
producers and they stop writing and and
maybe they're happier for that but I
think six months is a great time to
learn what it's like to be on the other
side of the fence because as a writer
your job is to write scripts that total
strangers will read and fall so in love
with that they're willing to go to their
boss and go to bat for you and you know
I'll put it an even more important way
when I was starting out I thought the
key was I had to get a manager and then
an agent I had to get people who were
out there advocating for me because I
can't do that you know as an unknown
writer I can't call up Warner Brothers
or Netflix and say hey you don't know me
but I wrote a script and it's great you
can't first well they're not going to
take your call right and good luck
getting through yeah right good luck if
you do Yeah right
so I thought I needed two people or at
least one person out there advocating
for me if you're really smart
that's not your objective your objective
is to get an army of people advocating
for you and the way to do that goes back
to writing pitch perfect authentic
scripts which I talked about in the
previous film courage videos check those
out if you haven't seen this because
when you write something that's unique
non formulaic with amazing characters an
engine an amazing concept people who
read it and I was one of those people
and I have a lot of students who are
these people they will to this a very
small community Hollywood and they will
email or call or text people and say if
you read Karen's script if you read this
script and they're like no and they're
like you should and they send the script
it's called the script travels well the
script goes viral and within days
everyone's has read it and everyone
wants to meet you know who you are
because your script has gone and
everyone's buzzing about it so when
you're writing a script the the so I'm
sorry I'm going a little bit off tangent
here but all I will bring it all
together in a moment so when I first
thing I do in my you say
class because they're so overly educated
they don't realize what a liability that
is what I'll say is you're writing I
could do it with a feature or a TV TV
script 60 minutes what has to happen
they say there's four scenes in act 1
what has to happen in that last scene
what's the objective of that scene and I
get incredibly smart answers you know
it's the point of no return it's the
first crisis it's the it's the first
subplot it's the reverse I mean I get
all these really smart answers they're
all wrong but they're really smart the
answer is the fourth scene what it must
do is get total strangers to have to
read the fifth C and the fifth scene has
to get read the six it's true every
scene every scene has to compel someone
to read the next scene and so that first
scene has to get someone to read the
second scene think about the first scene
as a first date you're not getting
married on that date they're not buying
your script the job of a first date is
to get a second date job of a second
date to get a third date now enough
dates in a row and then someone will be
like okay like I want to get in a
relationship with you that's the moment
when they're like I will read your whole
script they'll come a point where
someone will become such a fan because
they'll realize here's the concept I
know where this is going and I think
that's an awesome idea for a show or a
movie love these characters and and
these scenes are structured so tightly
and in such a compelling way I'm
starting to get confidence that this
person knows how to structure and at
some point you're like I will read this
to the end and then when you get to the
end your job is fun the fall in love and
when they fall in love that's when they
will tell everyone about your script
it's like you're watching a TV show that
you love and no one else is watching it
you're telling all your friends oh
you've got to watch the show you got to
watch the show we do that with scripts
so that's your job
so now that that statistic of 98%
sometimes people get mad at me and and
or they want to debate that number so
just to be clear that's not my number I
didn't come up here if you're upset
don't
directed at me I am just the messenger
it's very simple
I've been teaching at UCLA since 2007 I
have brought in countless executives
producers agents managers I always ask
these people the gatekeepers when you
get a script from a writer that's not a
current client and not an established
writer or a new writer how long do you
read to then decide if you're gonna keep
reading
and they always say one or two scenes I
have heard people say the first 10 pages
they were in a good mood but is usually
one or two scenes I ask those people
what percentage of the time do you keep
reading and I have heard 1% 2% far less
than 1% and it probably averages out to
about 1% but I tried to be a little more
optimistic and I made it 2% so when I
say 98% of non established writers if
they move mountains to get their script
into the marketplace
90% of the time people stopped reading
after one or two scenes that is solely
based on what all these producers agents
and managers and what my experience was
many years ago as a reader so anyone who
takes offense or son like that number I
didn't come up with it I am the
messenger sure and and then I I will
when I teach I'll say how many of you
right now are executives or readers or
story and listen there's usually like
six or seven hands that go up and I go
so let me ask you when I say only 2% of
scripts are continued to be read after
the first scene or two do you think
that's accurate do you think that's too
generous you think that's too
pessimistic and across the board they'll
say you're being way too generous you're
protecting these people it's less than
2%
oh so that's what these people are
saying and why is sometimes being too
smart getting in your own way yeah
because what happens is they they learn
all these rules so the industry has
changed so the industry is dramatically
changed
so it used to be that there were three
or four channels and basically what
everyone was doing there's Donald Glover
had a great interview on The New Yorker
about this the brilliant creator and
star of Atlantis so back in the day like
up to I don't know 2000 2002 whatever
you have three or four networks and that
was it and they were making macaroni and
cheese they were making comfort food you
come home after a long day and you want
a drama you want a comedy you want a
spiritual whatever and they would follow
paradigms so all the comedies were the
same structure different jokes and the
crime scenes you know CSI Hollywood CSI
Missouri CSI Australia
same structure just different crime and
the idea was we're creating comfort food
and what we're gonna do is put a star
that you like you like Ted Danson we're
gonna do macaroni and cheese but Ted you
like Hello yeah Ellen DeGeneres we're
gonna do macaroni and cheese with Ellen
DeGeneres and the truth is these shows
were designed to get the widest audience
possible ratings for advertising so they
wanted two shows to be watched by as
many people as possible so you wanna
show doesn't offend people you want to
show that a lot of people like and the
truth is people would watch a show and
they're like it's okay it's not great
but they don't change the channel
because they know there's nothing better
in the other two or three channels and
that says Ted Danson and I like Ted
Danson so I'll just stick with this
that's how it used to be and now there's
so much content that we know because we
have metadata that people sample pilots
and then it's like they're on a date for
10 minutes they're like well who else
can I date and they're just jumping and
what in most cases not all cases but in
most cases what determines success or
failure is follow-through simple simply
put what percentage of the people who
watch the first episode watch all the
episodes
that's follow-through because in a world
of too much content what you need is
brand loyalty you need people that will
stick with your show so girls I think
had about 2 million people watching it
that's not a large aggregate number but
I think it had one of the highest if not
the highest follow through well over 90
something percent of people who watch
the first episode of girls they watched
every episode of girls that's valuable
now because it used to be again
largest number possible and also to have
a lot of episodes to put it into
syndication very few shows go to
syndication there's just so much
original content so it's all about
creating shows that in a world of too
much content people are going to stick
with this show and so you see that a lot
of the scripts that are being bought
they're not the paradigm driven rule
driven script anymore they used to be
like if you go back 15 years ago you're
an unknown writer that's what you'd want
to write if you wanted to sell something
nowadays as my agent well my former
agent we don't have agents right now but
my former agent WME has repeatedly said
if you're doing a three camera standard
paradigm driven comedy or paradigm
driven procedural unless you've been an
executive producer or above in a hit
show in that space in the last three
years your scripts do a no-one's gonna
read it what you need to be doing is
writing a script that no one has seen
before writing something that only you
could have written and making an
elevated story so instead of preordained
plot points the the story unfolds
organically and it's not predictable and
it feels that characters are doing what
they would really be doing and saying
what they really be saying and it's
captivating these are the hardest
scripts to write these are the pitch
perfect authentic scripts but this is
what the majority of scripts that are
selling these are the scripts that are
selling now there are paradigm and rule
driven scripts that sell but they're
predominantly written by people who are
executive producers or above on those
hit shows and further it used to be if
you want to get staffed on a TV show
which is generally the entry way
starting place for a TV writer to get
staffed on an existing show work your
way up the ladder you would want to
write specs of existing show so if
you're a comedy writer you would write
spec episodes of hit comedies or spec
episodes of proceed
Durrell's almost no showrunner in town
would read dot script what they will
read is original scripts they and here's
why
they need their show to make an
emotional connection to the audience to
get follow through they need writers who
can create emotional attachment they
want to read your script and see that
you're a magician that you can write a
script that is unique that has
characters that just I have to keep
following these characters I have to
keep reading this script that's what
they're looking for when they staff
their show I have a friend as a
showrunner I mean he has a budget from
the streaming company for nine staff
writers and you only have seven because
he can't find nine because there's so
many shows and everyone who's good is
working and they're running shows or
they're the second that's a big problem
is getting enough really amazing writers
so the people coming out of these these
programs in a large a lot of time they
have been trained to fight a war that
ended seven years ago so what these
institutions are teaching was absolutely
true at the time and it's just it's a
lot harder for a big institution to sort
of change course for a lot of reasons so
anyway I'm not venomous a from UCLA I
love the experience I mean a lot of
great connections a lot of great friends
but but to answer your question I I find
a lot of I have a lot of agents and
managers send me writers to work with in
my workshops because they're overly
educated they know all the rules I know
all the paradigms their heads full of
what you can do or can't do it's
ridiculous when you see what is selling
when you see what show owners are
looking for they're looking for
something that is absolutely original
and captivating they don't want the
rules they don't want the paradigm they
don't that's that's easy they want
someone who could create something that
people is memorable it's impactful that
you have an emotional attachment to
because they need to create shows that
when someone watches it they will keep
watching that show so almost as if
you're talking about the marvelous
missus myzel Mazal myzel sorry it
it's almost that kind of that metaphor
of she was the perfect
whatever friend mother everything is
overly sanitized perfect but nobody
wants to watch that they want to see
somebody who's gonna really like like
push the envelope and offend people
possibly maybe not but but really like
go outside the lines yes that's really
the same thing with the writers it
sounds like yes that's really smart and
if we want to use more of us myths might
as well we can go a little bit deeper as
a metaphor cuz I he was a brilliant
metaphor in that show for writers so we
have a character who doesn't want to get
rejected so I mean as a wife she's taken
sex classes to be perfect in bed this is
in the show she not only have her makeup
on perfectly in her hair when she goes
to bed she wakes up an hour earlier oh
wow redoes her makeup and hair gargles
with mouthwash pretends to be asleep so
when the alarm goes off when her husband
wakes up she is a angel she's the
perfect daughter she's the perfect I
mean she's so charming and she's so
wonderful but it comes from this
terrible terrible fear of being rejected
so you already know as creating the show
she's gonna get rejected a lot by her
husband and by society and
her parents but to the metaphor I would
say then this I can relate to this as a
writer it was one of my biggest
struggles and I never overcame it and as
part of why I stopped writing and I see
a lot of writers with this struggle if
you are so afraid of rejection then it
makes you or it can compel you to be the
kind of person that you think people
want you to be and this could be true as
a son or a daughter or a spouse or a
writer so you start writing in a way
that you think is what people are
looking for and you're scared of writing
in a way that could offend people and so
people who are so terrified of rejection
can become the kind of person who it's
hard to reject but the person they
become is not who they really are so the
fear of rejection can lead people to
reject
themselves so afraid of being rejected
you reject who you truly are in the
marvelous miss myzel she has gone
through her whole life being a perfect
person at the end of that pilot she's
going to been the worst thing of her
life as her husband not only is he
reject her but who we rejected her for
and when he did it and she's drunk
Manischewitz fine but she is drunk and
gets on stage and for the first time
ever that character starts to search for
and to express her truth not as a
stand-up just because she's drunk and
she does and then Susie tells her you
are amazing you know this town as the
show unfolds what's fascinating is the
character exists in two spheres her
everyday normal sphere where she is a
perfect person and then a sphere where
she will continue to find and speak her
truth and that is on stage and really
the metaphor of the show that I take is
the only way to reach your full
potential as a creative person well this
would be true of anyone but let's stay
focused with writers the only way to
reach your true potential is to express
who you really are through your writing
to be completely authentic and and know
that people will reject that and be okay
with that you have to be willing to be
rejected to be authentic and I know
because I spent a decade as the studio
writer never being authentic in my
writing
and I wouldn't take any script that was
close to who I was and my agent was
repeatedly saying like you need to spec
something from your heart and I would
never do that because I was so terrified
of being rejected I knew at least if I
wrote a script that wasn't me I didn't
put myself into it if it got rejected
then my skill set my talent was being
rejected
I was terrifying to me but at least I
wasn't being rejected by I was authentic
in my writing as I as I knew I should be
and I was rejected that was just too
terrifying
so you know this is film courage courage
is so important and I lacked it as
rioter and that's part of why I teach
because I really want to do what I can
to help inspire other people to not make
that mistake and so I think the
marvelous is myzel is a really beautiful
metaphor and to really hit your full
potential you have to be okay with being
rejected and what will happen is you
will there were people who read the
pilot or they heard they did for
Seinfeld or you know catastrophe or
Breaking Bad or orange is the new black
Russian doll hated it I I was once the
some of your viewers might be a little
young to fully appreciate this but I was
out of studio one so I'm like I named
the studio for reasons that will become
clear and I was early for a meeting so I
was walking around and I kind of
wandered in an area I don't think I was
allowed to be and there was AI there was
a box of coverage reports covers reports
is when scripts go into the studio of
people write coverage
I saw a coverage report for Ferris
Bueller's Day Off that's represents a
minute that studio and they looked at
the coverage this person heeded that
script they said this is the most
annoying script I ever read first of all
you have a teen character who thinks
he's the smartest person he is and he
breaks the fourth wall and he talks to
us in such a cloying superior way and
it's like yes that was the magic of them
oh like you loved Ferris but the point
is you take any amazing project I'll
guarantee people told Quentin Tarantino
and they read pulp fiction if you move
forward with this you're going back to
the video store like this you this is
going to be a disaster of epic
proportions
there are people who read American
Beauty and said this is just stylized
melodrama there's nothing here all it
when you are your authentic self
you're going to have detractors and then
you're gonna have people that are gonna
fall in love and that's all you need is
one person to fall in love and then it
can change your life all it needs is one
person to say I'm making this
this is important and I'm doing it so
film courage writer courage is have the
courage to don't feel protected by the
rules and paradigms find what you're
trying to say create authentic
characters find the concept and go for
it and just write it completely not
worrying about being rejected and there
will be people who reject the script but
then people are gonna see who you really
are and what your voice truly is and
there going to be people who love it and
that's how someone launches a career in
the current marketplace Cori you said in
the beginning and believed of the last
question that you were listening or
reading an interview with Donald Glover
yeah I'm The Hollywood Reporter I'm I
think it was the New York The New Yorker
okay he was a New Yorker magazine and it
was a in-depth look at Donald Glover and
it was also talking about Atlanta which
if I'm correct has won more Awards in
his first two years than any TV show in
his first two years and Donna Glover was
talking about how it used to be where
they were trying to get the most people
possible to watch a show and now it was
following these paradigms and these
tropes Oh
people like families that argue then
come together and love each other then
people love a mystery with a red herring
and then you find out who did it so
everyone's doing the same generic
stories just with different dialogue or
different locations of different
characters but now in a world where
there's literally too much content
nobody can watch all of the shows
nobody knows all the new shows in a
world of too much content concept and
story are king yes you need great
characters but there's so many scripts
that have great characters and it's no
longer the case it just because you have
a certain star people are gonna watch
the show it's just too many show so what
he was the point he was making is oh and
there's a really great really great
funny quote I'll let I'll let people
read it so and there's a great quote and
there basically what he's saying is it
used to be getting the right actor
you know gimme a Ted Danson was the key
now it's the story in the concept that's
what differentiates and it's it's
telling a story in a unique way it's
telling the story in the way that's best
for that story and for the experience
you want people to have so Atlanta is
brilliantly structured it's one of the
shows that have a plot casting class and
we do case studies and teach people how
to deconstruct these shows to see how
they're put together and Atlanta is just
brilliant but if you look at any of the
paradigms or the rules that are widely
taught and then you look at the really
successful shows like Atlanta or the
marvelous missus myzel or fleabag or a
Russian doll and then if you also get
scripts that have launch writers careers
in the past four years and I've done
this with my UCLA classes just pile the
scripts have people grab whichever ones
they want and then the question is what
percentage of these scripts adhere to
the rules and the paradigms that you've
been taught and the answer ranges from
none to almost none and then people get
upset well why am i forcing a square peg
in a round hole and I don't have to
exactly so the the article that Dong
Glover was talking about the new
paradigm or the new reality of TV and
how the stories have to make an
emotional connection they can't be
predictable no the reality we know this
from the meditate metadata is that these
paradigm driven shows that's what our
parents watched you know we grew up and
came of age with on-demand video
platforms and we have as a generation
watch more TV than is probably medically
advisable we know what's a redo we know
what's a reheat and more and more our
generation is not watching those shows
you know Murder She Wrote which was a
brilliant show in its day that's what
our parents watched and so that was the
Donald Glover was making that argument
in a much
or articulate way than I just did and so
you can go look at it I'm it's in The
New Yorker two years ago or so do you
have any advice for writers on getting
the career they most want the writing
career and then first off how do they
even know what that looks like
yeah so I want to I want to relay
something that my favorite is when the
smartest agents ever what she said when
she came to my UCLA class so step one
ask yourself if I if I was guaranteed
success absolutely guarantee success
doing anything as a writer what would I
be doing and I want you to be specific
so don't say I want to write features do
you want to write Academy
award-nominated winning features do you
want to be writing directing small
interpersonal movies do you want to be
writing big popular culture successful
movies everyone's talking about
don't say I want to be doing 60-minute
TV what kind of system and be very
specific and what I really urge people
to do is for this exercise don't
constrain yourself by what you think is
possible like if you're like a lot to be
I'd love to create comedy shows but I
don't know if I'm funny enough well the
answer is if you were guaranteed success
what would you be doing and why and I
think there's a question writers should
ask themselves at least twice a year and
and anyone who's newer to this this
journey absolutely something to ask
yourself in you know I think part of
your question was well if someone's new
and inexperienced enough maybe they're
not entirely sure that's okay just write
down today what your answer would be
your answer can change over time as you
get more experienced the more education
but know what it is that you most know
what you would do if you were guaranteed
success and then the agent said now hear
me when I tell you nobody gets the
career they want you get the career you
deserve so the key is figure out the
career you most want then figure out how
to deserve that
and I'll get there in a second but I
just want to do a little quick personal
thing which is you know when we walk we
wear we look is where we move that's our
intent so when I was a young writer at
UCL I was very insecure didn't know if I
had what it took don't come from wealthy
parents I was on student aid and I
really had this idea of I need to know
if this is gonna work out for me because
if it is and I'm going to law school and
so I I made a promise to myself that
within one year I was going to sell a
script and 13 months later I sold a
pitch to Ridley Scott and I was willing
to say that counts and then really said
he was making the movie his front page a
variety and I was getting all of these
offers to write projects high-profile
projects for money at least for me I
didn't know people made that kind of
money I don't come from money but what I
realized is these weren't the kind of
things I wanted to be writing they were
the kind of movies I'd want to see but I
don't want to write these it's not it's
not creatively fulfilling I want to be
doing these and I was stupid or naive or
both enough to call my agent and say hey
I'm getting all these offers but I
really want these kind of offers I want
to be doing this and my agent took a
really long pause I think just to figure
out how the nicest way to say this but
in her own very very sweet way what she
said is if you wanted that career why
didn't you write the spec scripts
that get you that career because you
wrote the spec scripts to get you this
career and she said this is your career
so you're gonna follow this career for
five years and you were going to nail it
knock it out of the park and after five
years if you want to start talking about
how you might change the industry
perception of you and how you might want
to bend your career over there we can do
that but if I'm representing you for the
next five years this is your career
because that's the career you've
launched so there was a really important
question if that's the correct one why
did I write a script that launches this
career and the answer was I never asked
myself what kind of career I wanted my
intent was to launch a career and I
achieved that
my intent wasn't to launch the career I
most want and I worked with rioters
routinely who have careers who come to
me and they're like I want to change my
career I want to change what I'm known
for I wouldn't change a trajectory of my
career and they have very similar
stories so it's it takes a lot of effort
a lot of training a lot of hard work to
launch a career if you're going to do
that you might as well do it in service
of a career you most want or at least
that ought to be your plan a you know at
some point someone can say I've done all
this training I've done all this
dedication this is the career I want
it's just not happening for me maybe
there is a career a more suited for
maybe there's a different kind of
writing maybe it's not what I most love
doing but maybe I can make a living
doing that that's Plan B and there
certain is certainly our writers will do
that at some point they're like this
isn't working let me go to plan B but
for so many people like myself I just
started with Plan B and and for a lot of
writers maybe they would have gotten
what they most wanted if they went there
so that's why it's so important I
believe to start with what is the career
you most want and why because I think
you owe it to yourself to do what's
required to have to give yourself a shot
at that okay now the question becomes
you know the career you most want how do
you deserve that career then of course
it is writing the right scripts but what
people have to realize is it's not a
good script it's not a great script it's
an exceptional script so let me tell you
a true story Bruce Springsteen run the
greatest rock and roll gods of all time
he talks a lot about his life in the
Netflix special but there's a
documentary also if you can watch on the
making of Born to Run oh that sounds
good is really if you're if you if
you're like me and your nerd of the
creative process it's it's it's amazing
so Bruce Springsteen when the most
talented musicians to ever walk the
earth
dedicated you know all his friends are
going to college and
start you know jobs and starting
families he was just playing music for
free or for no money he was just all in
on having he want to be a rock star and
he was all in and he was mega talented
and he got a record deal which almost
nobody got and they promoted it and they
market it and they made radio stations
play as music this is the 1970s there's
no internet there's no Spotify there's
no iTunes if radio stations don't play
your music no one knows who you are they
don't want to play an unknown person but
Columbia Records could say do you want
the new Fleetwood Mac album do you want
the right that you're gonna play Bruce
Springsteen this number of times and
we're gonna have people listening to
make sure so all of that and the record
came out and it bombed now I always have
someone close to me who's mad they're
like it was brilliant you know I'm not
saying it wasn't artistically brilliant
I'm saying it commercially bombed bruce
says that and he got something very
people to get in the record business a
second chance and he poured heart and
soul and he knew the second album that
was this or or he was given up his dream
and the second album came out and it
bombed and God smiled on him he got a
third chance and that third album was
born to run his first two albums sold
42,000 copies born to run ten million
copies born run is considered one the
five greatest albums of all time he
became and remains a rock god in the
1970s if you want to be famous there's
two ways to do it be on the cover of
People magazine or Newsweek magazine
he's gonna cover both in the same week
oh wow so here's the question and this
is the question that anyone who once you
know the career you most want how you
deserve it here's my question for you
what was different about Bruce
Springsteen's third album than the first
two albums mmm the most popular guess I
get is luck gotta be in the right place
at the right time catch lightning in a
bottle luck is an excuse born run was a
trend send an album it would have been
goober successful if it was released
five years earlier five years later if
it was released today it is transcendent
it's not luck yes
you can write an amazing script and if
you're not in the right
place at the right time it may not sell
or get made that is true but if you
write a transcendent script you will
launch a career people want to work with
you they'll want to hear your pitches
they'll want to staff you so it's not
luck the other answer I get is that he
found his voice he found his authentic
voice no you go to the first two albums
and it is his authentic voice it is
Bruce
you hear that talent and that voice and
that melancholy and that aching and that
strength it
he had his voice hone in those first
year albums so he he didn't find his
voice he didn't get lucky so what is the
difference and the answer is Neal Landau
and Bruce Springsteen talks about it in
this documentary Neal Landau was a
reporter for The Rolling Stone who was
big fan of those first two albums and
came on board as a producer and he
produced Bruce Springsteen's third album
and they talked about it in his
documentary both Neal and Bruce what
Neal and Al did was he changed Bruce
Springsteen's process evolve Bruce
Springsteen's process just that much and
changing his process because process is
how we create product changing the
process that much can be the difference
between a failure and being a rock god
or a failure and being an a-list writer
a see this with writers they're like
this close and so it's changing your
process it's evolving your process and
almost every a-list writer I know will
say there was someone in my life a
manager a showrunner a producer who
helped me see a different creative way
of doing this an evolved way of doing it
changing your process so that is so key
for someone who's like this is the
career I want the way I deserve it is to
write just exceptional scripts okay how
do I write exceptional scripts well
talent you know make sure that you have
properly trained yourself to create
characters and dialogue that are
compelling compelling conflict I did all
this in a film courage video with the
essential tools so you can go back and
watch that video
then often the missing piece and this is
what I do my I have a three workshop
series in the first two workshops are
really teaching those skill sets and the
third workshop is all about process it's
all about evolving your process there's
a lot of things I do in that workshop
I'll I'll share one with your audience
so I'll share one specific tool and just
to be clear this is this is just one of
like 15 tools that are really important
but here's one and one of the tools that
I teach is the clarity index and so what
it it's a very simple tool when you are
trying to design and execute an
exceptional script so it's not following
the rules it's not paradigm driven it's
not predictable it's not character
serving preordained plot points but
you're trying to write a script like
Russian doll or Breaking Bad Pilar
Marvel's mrs. myzel or fleabag or we
could go on and on and on then you're
creating something original and I
guarantee you there's going to be at
least one or more times in that process
that's going to get really hard and it's
going to be really difficult to figure
something out how do I motivate the
character to do this or how do I solve
this dilemma that the characters in or
the there's there's a wide range of
structural design issues that can be
really challenging every writer goes
through that so when you're trying to
solve a really challenging creative
problem I ask people to think about a
spectrum between one and ten and one is
I have no idea in the world how to do
this I have I don't know the answer I
don't even know where to start looking
I am completely lost and a 10 is when
you can concisely
and precisely answer it when people hear
that answer they're like yes you know if
you go back and look at the creative
integration video for film courage like
their intuitive instinct just goes yes
and their conceptual analytical brain
goes yes so a 10 is that is that answer
and you can say it the more we have to
talk the less we know you can say it
concisely and precisely and in a room
everyone's just gonna look at you and go
yes so that's a 10 and a 1 is no idea I
don't even know where to look
so a 5 is like I have a sense the ideas
over here I think it's sort of shaped
this way but I don't know what it is you
know an 8 is I know the answer but I
can't precisely tell it to you if you
let me talk as I talk it's in there
somewhere maybe you can help me find it
because I know it's here but I can't I
don't know exactly where it exactly what
it that's like an 8 you know a 3 would
be I don't know the answer but I have a
pretty good sense I should look in this
direction ok so this is the spectrum so
the first thing that I want to train
people to do is know where you are know
where you are and understand that if
you're trying to write a script that can
change your life that can launch your
career or take I work a lot right now I
used to work with writers who were
trying to launch their careers I don't
do that anymore I now work I do that in
my workshops but one on one I primarily
work with people who've been staffed on
shows who are trying to get to the next
level so I tell them inherently you're
going to be at a1 or a2 in the beginning
here's one of the most important things
what is your relationship with being at
a low number a lot of writers get really
stressed they get anxious it's very
uncomfortable you're working on a script
check if I can't solve this problem the
script doesn't work and I have no idea
how to solve this problem I've been
thinking about it for three days and I
the the example I give that I can relate
to is whenever I park in a large parking
garage I can never find my car so if I'm
walking through a large parking garage I
know my car is there but I can't find it
it gets frustrating but imagine if I
don't even know if I drove the car there
now imagine if I don't even know if I
have a car because when you're at a low
number on this clarity spectrum you
don't know the answer you don't know if
there is an answer and if there is an
answer you don't know if you're gonna
find
you may not be able to find it there's
no guarantee and that freaks people out
and they get very stressed and
uncomfortable and we know about human
beings is there's an automatic part of
our brain that wants to when we get
stressed and freaked out wants to soothe
and comfort ourselves and we have
different ways of doing it here's a
whole bunch of really destructive ways
writers soothe themselves when they're
really freaked out about a really tough
problem they have no idea if they can
figure it out or not unfortunately I can
relate to almost all of these strategies
so one strategy is to convince yourself
it's not a problem I'm overthinking this
now I'm making a mountain out of a
molehill this is no one else is even
gonna see this problem and then that
calms you down
soozee down lets you keep writing and
then down the road when you give the
script to someone that you trust you're
gonna find out that this was a glaring
problem for them and the whole script
doesn't work so you're just kicking the
can down the road one of my favorite
strategies was to then another possible
strategy is to say now it's a really big
problem
it's got to be solved and they come up
with a kind of decent answer that's like
a 5 on the clarity spectrum and I
convinced myself it's a 10 I have an
answer that kind of works but it's not a
really great answer and I'm like perfect
once again you're gonna get your
comeuppance when people read your scrap
people you trust because you didn't
solve the problem and now they're a
mistake that people will make is they'll
say there just is no solution to this
problem that's why no one's done a TV
show I hear people say this all the time
like if Breaking Bad didn't exist you
could I could see someone saying that's
why no one's done a TV show about a guy
who cooks crystal meth because there's
no way to care about that guy no one
wants to spend time with a guy who cooks
crystal meth crystal meth is a scourge
of the universe or you know no I have
this great idea of doing a spy story
where the protagonists are Russian spies
they're Russian spies they coming to
America they are KGB agents they speak
perfect English they have kids they
pretend to be married and they undermine
the American Way and everyone's like oh
that's an interesting concept and then
it's like yeah but no one cares
these people were the stakes they're
gonna get caught oh no they're gonna get
caught
killing Americans undermining the
American Way they're the enemy well of
course that guy figured out how to do
that script and the Americans changed
his life not only did he sell that
script he was a showrunner in year 2 and
that that has won so many Emmys and best
drama and my point is any script that's
gonna change your life has something
about it that's really hard to figure
out and so what a lot of writers will do
is they'll say yeah banana for three or
four days or a week there is no solution
that's why no one's done a show like
this or maybe there's a solution that
someone smarter than me can figure out
and they just put that script away there
are so many writers who had an instinct
for something unique and special and
amazing have something really difficult
to figure out struggled with it and then
just put that in a drawer that's great
would have changed their life but it
went into a drawer the reality is the
writers who we all admire the writers
who create amazing shows
gave it chase really wanted to do a show
about what it's like to feel like your
mom is just crushing your life out of
you it's like she's killing you but you
can't escape her because you're Roman
Catholic it's your mom
and he couldn't figure out how to do
that with stakes took him two years he
talked about this two years to figure it
out he finally figured it out little
project called The Sopranos so the point
being how many people have a Sopranos or
a Breaking Bad or a fleabag that's just
in their drawer and it took David the
difference between David chase and most
writers or gingy Cohen and I think she
said took her like 11 months to figure
out how to do and solve some of the
problems and orange is a new black the
difference between gingy Cohen and David
chase isn't that they don't start at a
low number it isn't that they struggle
it isn't that they're lost it isn't they
go down a lot of dead alleys or you know
blind alleys that don't go anywhere
that's that that's not what's different
for them what's different is they don't
give up and they have a process to get
to attend but they don't give up so many
writers give up they they they
rationalize away the problem they
rationalize that a
okay Solutions a brilliant solution or
they just say well that's why no one did
can you know I have this great concept
but that's why no one's done it because
I can't work or the classic I need a
vacation from this I'll put it in a
drawer work on something else and I'll
go back to this and then they acquire
drawer full so what's really important
is to train yourself to expect to be at
a low number and to relax into the
unknown to be okay and then to have a
process to start moving up instead of
trying to find the solution start
brainstorming possible ways of
approaching the solution always be
looking for options always be
brainstorming possibilities that's the
way because when you're trying to find
the right solution you're so constricted
and that judgmental part is coming in
and throwing things away like no that's
not perfect but if you're brainstorming
options if you're just brainstorming
options for ways to find options then
you can relax that critical judgmental
mind and you can start wandering and
then you start moving up and you start
to have a sense and an idea and you
start to move up and most writers will
stop at a nine a lot of writers don't
know what a 10 feels like and so they're
always stopping at a nine so one of the
things that I do in the workshops is I
will bring in a creative problem that a
writer I worked with had and how this
was their first idea and how to solve it
and it clearly isn't very good and then
how they got all the way here to a
really good solution but it was like a
nine and then I give them the ten and
you can feel the difference I can't do
this here because I had permission to do
it in the workshops but people can go
through film courage videos there's a
lot of great writers talking and sharing
their stories and what I would be
looking for is so there are writers are
going to talk about how they got in the
business they're going to talk about
this project they're gonna talk about
how this came together and all that's
really interesting it can be educational
and inspiring but what I would really
pay attention to is a writer and I know
that this exists in in a lot of the
interviews
is look for a writer who's talking about
a really difficult creative process or
creative problem they're trying to solve
and then they give what the actual
solution was and you'll feel it you'll
feel like in so few words they just
nailed it so you need to know what a tin
feels like to hold yourself to ten so to
sort of wrap this all together I'll
share a true story my wife has a cousin
whose dream was to be a baseball player
and he was the best high school baseball
player in the eastern half the United
States and long story short when all his
friends went to college he went to the
Yankees he was 18 and he went to the
Yankees but in the minor league system
the the like triple-a and he was an
Adonis I'm an amongst boys he broke all
the batting home run records Defensive
Player of the Year and this guy was
going to be one of the greatest baseball
players of all time and a pretty young
age the at a pretty young age the
Yankees brought him up to the majors and
he was playing with his heroes and he
was just striking out striking out he
couldn't hit the ball so that's ok the
game a batting coach I said ecology
coach couldn't hit the ball so he put
him back down the minor at home run home
run home run brought him back up to the
major strikeout strikeout that's ok and
they just kept doing this for like four
years and they eventually cut him
another team the Cleveland Indians
picked him up same thing same cycle they
cut him another team with the three
teams same thing in the minor leagues
broke records in the major league he
could not hit the ball and then that was
over he was 27 years old and it was over
now he saved his money he went to
architect school met a wonderful woman
they're married have kids he's very
happy but here's an inch I didn't learn
this whole thing because it was with the
metal wedding and we were walking from
point A to point B which meant walking
over some grass he wouldn't do it he
walked a mile out of his way to not go
on grass and his wife's like yeah he
won't walk on grass
we don't have grass on our house he will
never walk on grass as an entire life
and I'm like I gotta have to hear this
story
central context what is this all about
sense memory it reminds him walking on
grass reminds about baseball and it
reminds him of his dream that he can't
ever have they just never walks on grass
so I asked him what's the difference
between hitting the best minor-league
pitch and an average major league pitch
and he looked at me and he said that
that's the difference and writers don't
understand that that doesn't seem like a
lot but when that's what stands between
you and your dream that's a lot and I
have writers that are sent to me by
agents and managers who are this close
and on the clarity spectrum they can get
to a nine they think it's a ten me no
one's gonna push that extra mile they
don't you know if you think you've ran
26.2 miles you're like I've done the
marathon and you can stop but what if
you've only gone 25 miles that's what a
really good manager will do for you is
they believe is really good it's not yet
exceptional you've got to make it that
much better
because nobody does that on their own
because they don't realize it could be
that much better you know when I was
starting out the greatest gift my
manager gave me is he held me to a
standard I didn't think I could hit and
he said I know you can hit that standard
I don't know if he really thought that
or not but I needed to hear that and so
the clarity spectrum is not making the
mistakes at the smaller number yeah and
as you go through life and you you watch
film courage videos or you know writer
podcasts or you go to events where you
hear writers talk you will hear writers
talk about creative problems or if they
talk about a creative problem they
didn't talk about solution try to social
media them or go up them after the event
and just say hey I'm a writer and you
were talking about in the script you
were struggling with this I'm really
curious like how did you what was your
process how did you get to an answer
what was that answer in my I did it all
I just all the time with writers they're
usually excited to share this you know
they usually people come up to them it's
like how do I get it agent well you read
my script but if you approach a writer
and you're like I just want to learn
what your process was and what was the
solution
they'll share it with you and if you do
that pay attention to how few of work
how few words they use to give the
answer
and how when you hear that answer how it
makes you feel like there's a tuning
fork inside you where you're like yeah
yeah yeah no that's it that's brilliant
and that's what @n feels like and you
know what @n feels like then you'll know
when you're not quite there you had
talked about in the last film courage
interview that you read rewrites the
memoir by Neil Simon yeah and I just
briefly skimmed the book on Amazon and
he kind of talked about the same thing
he in terms of being unhappy working in
LA on a television show and he was like
if I don't I think his quote was if I
don't start writing a Broadway play soon
I wouldn't inevitably become a permanent
part of the West Coast typography this
very thought of that jump started me to
my desk so but but do you think it he
was 30 I think when he was talking about
that do you think most writers know they
just kind of think about that same thing
that you like I've got to get signed
I've got to get yeah you know and and
how do they even know that this is the
wrong genre or type of writing job for
them you might not so a mistake that I
made and I think I made a lot of stupid
mistakes this mistake I don't beat
myself up too much because they think
this is a pretty understandable mistake
and I see writers make this which is
just because you love a certain TV show
or a certain movie or a certain genre TV
or a movie or a certain genre doesn't
mean you love writing it it might I mean
you know fleabag is your your all-time
favorite TV show and you could write
something like that you might love it
you might not so what I suggest is
especially if you're new instead of
picking this is the kind of writer I'm
gonna be playing with it and write 10 or
15 pages of this kind of a thing and
Center 50 page of this kind of thing
Tennant and don't worry if it's great
don't worry about the engine and the
concepts and all that just see what is
my experience in writing these pages
just experiment it's like being a young
kid in an attic and sure
different clothes and you pretend to be
different people what what person what
type of writing really excited you I'll
tell you one of the things that I have
routinely see when I'll work with a
writer you know we always start with an
entry in an initial kind of interview
conversation and there and the writer
will always say you know this is the
kind of stuff I write this is what I
think's in my wheelhouse
this is the stuff that I would suck at
and I always make them try to do what
they think they'd suck at like again not
an entire spread you know maybe just a
couple days an assignment it's not that
in common that someone when they do this
it's like holy shit it's so good and I
loved it and I've seen writers who've
had this career and they play around
with what they know they wouldn't be too
good at and they go on I have huge
careers not saying that's always the
case so experiment sort of you know just
like maybe when someone's a young person
they're not really sure who they want to
be in a long-term relationship maybe you
date around and you you meet different
people and you date different people
maybe date people you wouldn't think of
dating just to see what the experience
is like the same date different kinds of
writing but yeah it's really it's it is
uncut is common that writers will have a
career and then discover that's not what
I want to be doing that's very common I
mean just talk to agents or managers
they have a lot of good friends or
agents they they hear this all the time
his early success in the entertainment
industry a blessing or a curse such a
fascinating question I think it could be
both I mean I think it could be a
blessing for someone it could be a curse
for someone it could be both and I see
that I'll talk about myself I had very
early success I was had been in film
school year when I sold pitch to really
Scott frontpage a variety really is
making the movie ultimately didn't but
it was a front page of variety every
studio was fighting for me in some ways
I feel so blessed and lucky because I
deal with writers who have so much
talent and passion and they've been at
it for three years five years seven
years ten years in they for goad they've
forgotten a career and another career
you know
they are just working on writing they
have a day job to pay the bills they're
not living the lifestyle they want
because everything is about their
writing and they have this just is it
gonna happen for me and and you know I
want to be married I want to have kids
and like if I'm gonna pivot I should do
it soon I don't want to keep doing this
if it's not gonna work out for me I
don't want to pivot if it's about to
work out for me what do I do it's such a
for someone to ask me that they've got
to be in a lot of pain to ask because no
one else can answer I think God I never
had to go through that it all happened
so quickly for me so like to happen was
a huge blessing I have to deal with that
and I see so many writers make it so
much harder on themselves than they have
to because they're so impatient you know
that I've written this number of scripts
and I've been in at this amount of time
and it's got this next one has to happen
they may just put all the weight of the
world on their next project and that's a
big reason why they don't actually get
to attend and we were talking about the
clarity spectrum in that previous video
that process video because they just
they've got to get this thing out there
and it's got to sell because if it
doesn't and they're going to go back to
law school or graduate school or
whatever so certainly a blessing to
don't have to go through that it's also
a blessing because I I learned a lot as
in my first couple of assignments and I
had producers and directors teach me so
much and I was getting paid I was
getting paid good amount of money to
learn and get better so especially if
you know for someone that doesn't have a
lot of money that's a nice way of
learning because you you're gaining
access to Ridley Scott you're getting
access to Wolfgang Petersen you're
getting access for me like working title
I was getting access that's the thing
that is sort of heartbreaking is that
when my career was started and it was
going really big I was going to all
these parties and I was meeting the Coen
brothers I was mean Quentin Tarantino I
was talking to them about craft and
process and learning from them and then
my day job as I was working for working
title I think are the smartest producers
I ever met and Ridley Scott and his team
like I had act
says to everything that an aspiring
writer needs but for the most part it's
only the people who have success that
have access to that and for them I
needed access to that because I didn't
know what I didn't know but most writers
who have access to all that they they're
already amazing writers so it's like the
people that need access to these people
can't get access to the people so gave
me access to people who were so
successful and smarter than me who are
willing to help me I got paid to learn
and I didn't have to go through that
incredibly emotional struggle of how
long do I do this so I'm forever
grateful for all of that and so that was
just straight-up blessings you know and
for some people it's just a straight-up
blessing but there can be some curses to
it you know for me it just came so easy
and the right out of the gate I was
working with his amazing people and
getting paid all this money I was so
young and so naive and so stupid I just
thought that's normal that's just how
it's going to be you know I mean Studios
were flying me first class and it was
just this amazing life and then when my
career took a dip it was just question
for me you know because I had an
entitlement I didn't I hadn't been
forged in the fire of what this is like
people who struggle for a while they
will they will develop a stronger
process one of the reasons that I never
have a success that I wanted and part of
reason I walked away from writing after
10 years is I had such a painful
relationship with and I talked about the
sex fear of rejection and I was never
really writing to my best ability and I
was pulling my punches and for the most
part I hated writing and I don't know if
it would have been different if I didn't
have success early on but what the
writers I work with I always tell them
your blessing right now that you're not
you don't have a career is you get to
work on your relationship with writing
you get to experiment like we've been
talking about these other videos you get
to evolve your process I couldn't do
that really because you know it's really
Scott had six weeks to write a script
that's not a time to be experimenting
with you
that's not a time to be saying oh I have
this strength but I have this weakness
as a writer let me just put this on hold
and find a class or a workshop that can
help me turn this weakness into a
strength no it's like you go to war with
the army you have like I have to write
the script to the best of my ability and
then I just got on this lake I was like
an addict I just wanted another deal
more money another deal I never was
willing to stop and develop myself and I
know so many managers and agents but
particularly managers it drives them
crazy because though a writer is good
enough to have a career but they're not
quite good enough to have the career
they want and they won't get off the
gravy train there's this fear of I see
it in the writers I work with I saw it
in myself which is if I don't take this
deal I'll never get another deal you
know cuz someday the inertia is gonna
wake up and realize they made a mistake
with me I don't know what I'm doing and
I'm no good and so every deal was the
last deal so like me do this and Bank
the money and then I'll go train myself
but no then it was a new deal and you a
mage at some point said you're a crack
addict like this I mean you'reyou're
addicted to these deals you're never
gonna stop doing this and it was true
you know then my father passed away and
it just changed everything and and then
I walked away but so I tell people you
know who it's not happening for them
right away which is north that's the I
was incredibly just fortunate I had some
really good mentoring some really good
training by people and I was at the
right place at the right time so it was
just very fortunate but people who the
normal experience that's not the case I
just worked with a writer I'm gonna see
him actually tomorrow night he's been at
it for six years and he just sold three
feature scripts but in those years what
his blessing was that he really got to
change his relationship to writing he
got to realize that he has inherent
strengths weaknesses and blind spots
blind spots are weaknesses we don't know
we have and he was willing and had the
mindset to find people to help show him
as planning spots and how to attack
weaknesses and turn them into strengths
that that's entirely what I do
philosophically in my workshop
and so people not necessarily my
workshops wherever you do it you have
the opportunity to not only become a
stronger writer but change your
relationship with writing where you're
not so afraid of rejection and you're
not so favored to other you you have a
cord and you and no one can take that
from you no one can take your voice from
you no one can take your integrity from
you and you really have a you can really
Forge that in the fire of not succeeding
and then when you do get a career you
could be more likely to make smarter
decisions stand up for yourself say no
to projects because that's the thing
like I have no financial safety net and
I had all these loans to pay off and I
just felt like they're offering me this
amount of money I never can make that
amount of money doing anything else I
have to say yes but people who have gone
four or five years without success that
you know how to survive you know they
know how to financially take care of
themselves so if they are in a situation
where someone's offering them a deal to
do a project and they know in their
heart of hearts it's not a good move for
them it's not moving them to where they
want to get to they might have more
strength than saying no you know cuz the
idea of like okay so let's just say I
say no a couple times and I stopped
getting offers and I got to go back and
write us back they're like well I've
done that I survived that so I mean I if
I had to choose I would have chosen
launching a career early on I think
there's a lot of blessings in that but I
think there could also be a lot of
blessings in having a struggle a while
find your voice find your integrity find
why you're doing this change your
process evolve your process and get
stronger as a writer so then when it
does happen for you you can really have
the career you most want
in our 2017 interview Cory we touched
someone on on Battlefield Earth so maybe
we can talk about it again and that is I
believe you're one of the co writers on
the movie can you explain what happened
and also help explain to other
screenwriters maybe what could possibly
happen to them sure
thanks for bringing that up Oh sir yeah
I'm here to open old wounds yeah so let
me I'll walk you through sort of what
happened and how it happened
but then I with your permission I want
to back up and sort of talk about a more
important aspect so what happened is I I
felt like I was so unlucky out of the
gate well no I felt incredibly fortunate
I sold this pitch release guy was gonna
make it he almost made it but then there
was just all this crazy stuff with
German investment studio politics just
all the stuff that nothing to do with me
or the script that didn't get me to
Prague two projects later of a director
of a greenlit movie studio greenlit
movie director in Africa scouting
locations and then the head of studio
lost his job the new person came in and
shut down all of the projects that the
previous person had greenlit so that now
it was dead and I could go on I had five
projects in the first five years that
were greenlit but didn't get made and so
I just thought god hates me and I'm the
unluckiest person in the world and then
I met more and more writers who had the
exact same stories and I realized oh
it's not that God hates me
God hates writers and it's just this is
just the nature of the beast
now I so I had a so I'm sorry so what
happened is the last time I had I'd
written script that almost got made but
the star backed out and it's just so
clear you need a star to get it over the
finish line so I got a call from agent
saying that they want to meet you at MGM
John Travolta was a huge star at the
time
and for Balfour so I want you to go take
the meeting do not say yes to do not
take the project but meet John Travolta
and his producing partner these are good
relationships and you're going to meet
the head of the studio the head of MGM
so I went in and took the meeting and
they told me what I wanted to hear and I
wanted to hear it and they told me this
has nothing to do with Scientology you
know we had a science we had a writer
from Scientology and the script is
completely unusable we're not following
the book literally in fact John's gonna
play the main character and the main
character in the book is like a young
like 17 year old or 18 year old and you
know John's a middle-aged man at this
point and we spent a big Star Wars movie
and it's gonna be really fun and and
just told me everything I'm on here and
John Travolta was like it was really
good that make me feel really special
and this is gonna be a great movie and
all of this and I was very respectful
but I I said no but I was really tempted
because I'm like this will get made and
this could be a big fun Star Wars movie
maybe and it has Travolta he's very
motivated to do this but I said no it
was really hard because at the point I
was feeling like if I don't get
something made no one's gonna hire me
again because you can write some scripts
that get close to being made and they
don't get me but at some point if you've
written five six seven scripts that
haven't actually got made then at some
point people are gonna blame you and I
really felt like I was and I went in
there I was getting there so then it
leaves MGM and it goes to Fox 2000 they
pick it up and Laura Ziskin is running
Fox 2000 and she came she was when the
first industry people ever met because I
was in film school and she came to speak
to us and I was mesmerised she's so
intelligent and she's just so amazing
and just feels it's just so much ethics
and has was involved in some of my
favorite movies
so they once again made a run at me and
I had dinner and I said yes and Fox mm
you know they were very clear like this
has got nothing to do with Scientology
and it's going to be this kind of a
movie
all that I felt very secure in saying
yes now I want to be clear
my wife said don't say yes my agent said
don't say yes my friend said don't say
yes my Golden Retriever Toby said don't
say yes in his own Golden Retriever way
so so everyone else was saying don't do
it but I did it and I'm gonna come back
to why I said yes the real reason I said
yes I'm gonna come back to that but I
said yes and I got paid a lot of money
and I wrote this crap and two or three
days before I turn the script in Fox
2000 was out there was a change with
Laura I mean Fox 2000 was out and the
project got picked up by franchise films
which isn't a real film company there
are a financing company since gotten a
lot of trouble but so when I turned the
script in there was no studio there were
no executives it was just John and his
producing partner and as far as I can
tell spiritual advisors came in to fill
that void because there's no real record
of what the development was at that
point because it was no longer a studio
movie and so there were changes to the
script yeah I was not involved in and
then the movie got made and and it had a
miniscule budget for the special effects
and it was terrible and I don't mean to
be offensive thing was a Scientologist
but in the industry that was not seen as
a positive in fact I went on I could
round of meetings for a year after that
movie where people just brought me in to
see how did this happen and are you a
Scientologist everyone wanted to know if
I was a Scientologist which I am NOT and
so yeah so basically the once you turn a
script in you don't own that script you
have no control over the changes if it's
a studio film there's going to be a
record of the developmental changes
there was no record nobody well some
people no I have no idea who I've heard
rumors but I have no idea who rewrote it
and why but they rewrote it back to the
book and then John for some reason
decided instead of playing the
seventeen-year-old character he was
gonna play the space alien he was gonna
play like this giant space alien which I
don't think was
the best choice so anyway the movie was
just a complete unmitigated disaster I
remember I was in Vegas when it came out
I was so depressed cuz I was like that's
it my writing career is over
I was actually secretly a little
relieved but I was mostly depressed I
remember talking to my agent who like
talked me off the ledge he needs like
people in this industry know what
happened and they are not gonna hold
this against you and your career is not
over it's gonna be a little more
challenging but your careers not over if
this ever happens again your career is
over
that you can survive this one and again
just I think I was just so blessed and
fortunate I continued to work as a
writer at my full quote with heads of
Studios major directors for four more
years like it should have ended my
career I was fortunate that I had a
track record of writing scripts that had
attracted major elements that almost got
made didn't get made so I had that so
people were willing to say okay this was
an unmitigated disaster we're not gonna
hold this one against you and and I got
to keep working I think if I was a newer
writer without that track record it
would've been over for me but I want to
I want to sort of back up because all of
that kind of does it kind of it kind of
divorces me of a lot of the
responsibility is sort of like okay I
knew I shouldn't say yes but I said yes
and then right for a turn the script in
the studio backed out and it was
franchise films and and all that's true
but I wanna back up after the really
Scott deal happened an agent Barbra
Dreyfus was an agent at the time just
she wasn't my agent but she was such a
good person
that she took me out to lunch if that
wasn't her client and she said Cory the
script that you wrote to get your career
and the script you wrote for metropolis
that really is going to make now is not
the most important script of your career
is the next script that you write
because now you're on the radar now
people know who
you are this next script will seal your
fate
this next script will put you on a
trajectory what career do you most want
and that's what the script needs to be
people are gonna offer you a lot of
money to write scripts that you don't
want to write you have to say no you
will be scared that the offers will will
slow down and they may not come you have
to take that risk
the offers won't slow down worst case
everyone offers a script everyone offers
your project to write and you don't want
to write it you say no to everything and
worst case they stop offering you things
write a spec you have to write the
script that you most want to write that
is authentic you have to write the
script that you're going to that is
going to be a 10 on a scale in the tents
gotta be exceptional because this next
script is going to seal your fade down
the road if you want to take a project
just for because you're getting paid
obscene amount of money you can do that
down the road not right now and it was
one of those times when when she said
that I Scott this chill up my spine
I'm like this is true I was offered a
project I didn't want to write I said no
I was offered another project I said no
the studio came back and offered me more
money I said no they came back and
offered me a lot more money I thought
about it I said go on write the script I
absolutely do not want to write this
crap I said no it's really hard then
they said we want to meet with you at
least so I went to meet to get the
relationship and in the room they
offered me more money and they talked it
all up and they played in my ego and I
said yes so there I was I I failed this
test really early on and like from that
moment on I was just I was always
reacting I didn't have a center I was
just reacting I was scared I just wanted
more I just wanted I didn't want the
deals to end and I just kept taking
deals that in my soul I knew I shouldn't
be taking but I did and if you do that
over time it's going to lead to
Battlefield Earth if you just keep
reacting and you don't find your
integrity in your Center and you just
give your power to the industry and do
whatever it takes to keep getting work
it's going to end terrible
I feel like I completely deserve battle
filter it was the I was just making
reactive fear-based decisions and that's
what it leads you to and I was able to
talk myself into taking that project yes
I didn't know Fox 2000 would drop out I
had no idea about fan choice films there
was a lot I couldn't foresee but I knew
in my heart that I should say no and I
said yes
so I own that and I deserve that I can
now look back at it and say it was it
was literally one of the greatest things
that have ever happened in my life
because I was so afraid of rejection I
was so afraid about other people thought
this movie came out and like you could
imagine looking through the LA Times or
the New York Times at the reviews I mean
they were brutal I mean this this movie
is a punchline to jokes today I mean
this is considered one of the worst
movies of all time and I am one of the
credited writers and even though most
people don't understand how the industry
works and what that really means I am
one of the credited writers I'm one of
the worst movies of all time I you for
me like there was no greater sense of
rejection or shame it was it was beyond
what I was most afraid of didn't kill me
I came out of it stronger I came out of
it humbled I came out of it for the
first time starting to hear that voice
inside me I started to pay attention to
who I was I started to realize and then
when my father died I realized life
doesn't last forever
and I realized that I'd been living my
life based making all these fear-based
decisions and not saying Who am I and
what matters to me and why am I on this
planet and those questions and that led
me ultimately after 40 I worked for four
years after Reiki oh I wish I was
breaking bad Battlefield Earth I worked
for four years after that and then I
walked away and just
to be clear I don't want to make it look
like I was at the height of my career
and I walked away the offers were
getting harder and harder they were
slowing up it was getting harder and
harder to book a job I felt like I could
squeeze another one out but I walked
away because I didn't want to write I
didn't want to do this anymore and the
one thing that I've loved in life is
teaching and I was teaching at UCLA like
once a year for for the fun of it when I
was writing and I remember talking to my
wife and I'm like if I could just teach
like I feel like that's my purpose and
she's like then that's what you're gonna
do and I was saying I can't make that
fear voice was still there like I can't
make any money doing that and she's like
do it you you you just spent 10 years
doing something for the money and you
were miserable I mean I I waited like 40
pounds more than this I treated myself
and other people badly has so much pain
so much rage geez you deserve now we got
money in the bank for now
you deserve to to pursue just what you
love just try it
so I did and in it I am so proud of I
have six teachers now teaching under me
I'm so proud of what we built over the
last seven years I'm so proud of
everyone has gone through our program
who's now working and selling stuff and
I would never be the teacher I was today
if it wasn't for Battlefield Earth I'll
just talk about process and creative
integration and it all came from that
pain that I own that it was my fault
that it happened yeah I said yes when I
knew I shouldn't and it was the best
thing that ever happened to me you know
from that moment on it's like when I
would I want to make an instinct or I
have to make a decision in my my
instinct is to do this but I have this
fear voice of what what would people
think or you could be rejected it's like
well it ain't gonna be a bad as battle
filler you know and I survived that so
yeah it really softened me and it really
made me like really pay attention to
like my instincts and my impulses and
that that's allowed me to be the teacher
that I am so I think everything happens
for a reason and I think that I was put
on this or
to teach and Bala fell earth was a big
part of that and it's it was a big part
of my training to be the teacher that I
am and I remember when I first started
teaching like well no one's gonna take a
class for me like who's gonna say hmm
let's take a writing class from the guy
who wrote one of the worst movies ever
it I can't explain it but ever since I
started like my classes are sold out we
we have waiting lists as I said I have
six teachers that teach under me I don't
know why but but I think people it's all
referral-based and I think people
realize that what we're teaching no one
else is teaching we're really teaching
people how to change your relationship
with writing how to change your process
and how to become an even better writer
than you knew you could be we're not
teaching paradigms and rules we're
actually teaching people how to be
writers so sorry if I overreacted but
and there's anything else that you're
curious about in terms of bath or thumb
I'm happy to answer it don't you think
it's it's almost better to have someone
who's gone through so many ups and downs
teach something rather than somebody
who's either flatlined or yeah it's been
just nothing but successes well how
somebody get up always because most
people's careers are never just a
straight line it's not yes I agree and I
mean so first of all I feel so it's just
the danger of over answering it I think
what I do uniquely as a teacher is that
I can help writers recognize their
process you know you're in charge of
your process or your process is in
charge of you and for so many creative
people they're not fully aware and
responsible for their process they're
not in charge of their process and I'm
really good and working with writers to
figure out like where their pain and
fear is and where they have an unhealthy
relationship and where it's sabotaging
them and what they can do to get to heal
that and to evolve their process to
become a much better writer and part of
it is the whole time I was writing I was
obsessed with process I talked to every
successful writer every unsuccessful
writer but particularly success writers
and I wanted to know what's your process
what's your process because I was I
thought if I could
you're out the right process I could
heal myself I could change my
relationship with writing it was really
painful to know I was getting paid a lot
of money and I was writing something but
I was never even close to my potential
like I knew I was so much better than I
was then I was limiting myself to be so
I was always looking for a better
process and and it never helped me I
couldn't overcome my demons but I I have
an encyclopedic I just I didn't have any
cyclic knowledge of writer processes so
when I worked with writers I think
especially because I I fought so hard
against my demons and I never actually
overcame them I think I'm really attuned
to people fight with their demons and so
when I first started teaching to be
perfectly honest I taught to get out of
the house I talked those lonely as a
writer I talked because it was fun I
talk because I wanted to be a stand-up
so at least I it was sort of a way of
performing but the real reason I was
teaching is I wanted to help people
evolve their process heal their process
I wanted people I want to teach people I
want to teach people how they could
become reach their full potential
because I figured if I could do that for
someone else that I would know how to do
it for myself and what I found is I'm
really good at doing it for other people
and I can't do it for myself so so yes
to rap back to your question I think
there are people who just know nothing
but success they're really smart I think
they can give really good feedback on a
script I think they're really smart and
they can really be beneficial but often
in terms of process they don't even know
they're doing things about knowing
they're doing it and they can't always
empathize or connect with people who are
struggling in certain ways so yeah I
think the fact that in some ways you
know I did a 19-4 hire studio projects I
worked with great people I got really
close on some projects I made good money
in some ways I was very successful in
terms of credits and Battlefield Earth
and and enjoying writing and feeling
like I was writing the best of
my potential I was a failure so I feel
like I was both successful and a failure
depend on how you want to look at it and
I do think that really helps me as a
teacher because I can work with someone
who's brand-new who's really struggling
as we know why they're struggling and I
work right now with a lot of show
runners who are so amazing but they just
want to get that much better so I can I
can use all of all of that collective
experience and I think that I in a lot
of ways I think my writing career was
there to launch my teaching career I
just didn't know it at the time it is
yeah
a question that comes up a lot amongst
creative people do you have to live in
LA to launch a career yeah especially in
writing yeah you don't have to live in
LA to launch a career but it's gonna be
harder if you don't in certain way so
what I would say is first of all think
about their stages so the first stage is
writer development you know most people
start out they don't quite realize how
hard it is and they have a little bit of
a exuberant exuberant confidence which i
think is great because it gets you
writing you know I know for myself if I
knew how hard it was gonna be I don't
think I would have even started when I
first I'm like oh I'm good this isn't
that hard I've seen this is as good as
that movie and and then at some point
comes the point where someone tells you
and shows you you're not close to where
you need to be and then the question is
what are you gonna do about that and so
there's the phase of writer development
and I've talked about this and I won't
go into too much detail cuz it's in a
lot of the videos that I've done for you
guys at film courage but it just briefly
is everyone has inherent strengths
weaknesses and blind spots and your job
is to figure out have someone help you
figure out what of the blind spots so
they become known weaknesses and then
how do you attack weaknesses and turn
them into strengths how do you do
structured exercises they're a little
bit beyond what you're capable of so
you're going to fail but you're gonna
learn from those failures and eventually
be able to do it so then you're going to
become better if you just keep doing
that so Dziedzic li you can become
enormous ly better so the first phase is
writer development you do not have to be
in LA there are advantages and
disadvantages to being in LA there are a
lot of classes and workshops and so much
educational opportunities in LA but the
great thing with the internet my
workshops are online video conferencing
you have people all over the role take
them I'm not the only one
there's certainly if you want to take
classes or workshops there are a
multitude of options that you can do why
you don't live in LA also you know in LA
you can go to the writers guild you can
go to there's these events where writers
talk well if you don't live in LA you
can watch the film
videos and online you have so much
access so in terms of education now you
can do that anywhere an advantage of LA
is you're going to be around like-minded
people forming communities you know when
I went to film school I didn't grow up
in LA when I came down here you know was
a bunch of us we all have the same crazy
dream we supported each other we watched
movies together we discussed movies we
we read each other scripts who really
helped each other and when one of us was
feeling down the other people would
encourage them you can do that anywhere
in the world now with social media like
you you have to put more effort into it
but you can create communities I don't
think it's the same as face-to-face but
I think if you live somewhere in the
world outside of LA you can educate
yourself you can grow your talent you
can form communities but have to work
harder at it it might not be quite as
enriching as if you were in LA but you
can certainly do all that and let's not
forget LA is a high cost of living place
to live you know for people sometimes I
live in LA they have families they have
careers they have businesses there's a
lot of costs involved to move to LA so
you when you're developing your
abilities getting to the point where you
can write the kind of script that can
launch your career you don't have to be
in LA and there's an advantage of not
being in LA because the biggest mistake
writers make when they're in LA is to
keep meeting people in the industry and
networking and they show scripts to
people before they're ready before the
scripts are good enough and they blow
their first impressions and they can get
blacklisted so there's an advantage to
being outside of LA while you develop
your abilities now let's say a writer
has gone through the developmental stage
and they have scripts at least two that
are good enough to get representation
and to be shown and start to take
meetings so then let's call this the
launching of the career phase this is
where it's very advantageous to be in LA
it's not a require you don't absolutely
have to but it's very advantageous so if
you're not in LA what's gonna at a
minimum you're gonna have to go to come
to LA
for two or three weeks a two or
three-week block multiple times a year
because what's gonna happen is your
representation is going to take your
script out to various you know producers
networks cable companies streaming
companies also they might be showing to
show runners and there's gonna be a
round of meetings 20 meetings 25
meetings some of these meetings are
generals where they're like loved your
scrap we can't buy it but we want to
meet you they want to see who you are I
want to make sure that you're someone
they want to work with they want to have
a relationship with you they want to
read your next script some of these
meetings are you're gonna be pitching a
project we loved your script I wish we
could buy it can't but we want to be in
business with you
what ideas do you have it's easier to
sell a pitch than a spec in the TV
industry most projects are sold via
pitch so you're going on pitch meetings
and you know you pitch at a company and
then they'll bring you back to meet
someone else then someone shows up
there's a series that I met three people
that's got free before I met with Ridley
and pitch to Ridley or you might be
meeting with showrunners who might be
interested in possibly staff in you on a
show so there's a round of meetings and
at the end of that round maybe someone's
bought the script or your pitch or
staffed you and maybe not and if not you
write your next script and you go on
another round of meetings and as my
agent said if you go through three or
four rounds of these meetings and no one
is hired you then you're the biggest a
hole in the room like there's something
just wrong with you that nobody wants to
be working with you but assuming you're
not that person three or four rounds of
meetings you're gonna get your shot so
at a minimum you'd have to let your
representation know I can be in LA like
for this two or three week window and
then they're gonna try to schedule all
those meetings in those two or three
weeks here's a challenge there might be
some great meetings you're gonna miss
because they can't fit it into those two
or three weeks the other thing is very
common the night before a meeting or the
day of the meeting they reschedule and
that's actually often a good thing
because as you work your way up you're
starting
to meet with more senior people at the
company you could actually have the
authority to hire you or by a pitch or
the script but they are overseen
productions they have a very chaotic
life and they don't have complete
control over their schedule so they're
not being rude but a lot of meetings get
bumped and rescheduled so if you're only
here for two or three weeks that meaning
may never get rescheduled or it'll get
rescheduled but you may not be able to
do it or what happened to me as I
pitched to some people that scot-free
and they said really is out of the
country for a month well schedule when
he comes back because he has to hear the
pitch and then I got a call like three
days later from my agent saying Ridley's
in town today he has a window can you be
there in an hour
because he wants to hear the pitch now
if I was back in New York or Toronto or
Topeka Kansas that meeting doesn't
happen does that mean I never would have
sold metropolis the pitch - really I
don't know maybe maybe not but the
advantage of being in LA is you can do a
last-minute meeting and when meetings
get reshuffled you can always attend so
it's not ideal to come out so what I
would say is in the writer development
phase it doesn't really matter where you
live in the launching if you can come
here for six months or a year it's going
to be helpful it's going to increase
your chances
I know agents and managers that won't
sign someone who doesn't live in LA
because it's gonna be harder I know more
agents and managers who would sign
someone who doesn't live in LA but if
they're trying to sign two people to
sign and they feel pretty equal about
both of them and this person lives in LA
and this person doesn't they're gonna go
with this person and not this person but
if this person is so exceptional they'll
sign them all so you know you can always
do meetings over Skype but it's not the
same you want to be in the room if you
can I have worked with writers in South
Africa in Australia in Alaska who have
launched careers that did not live in LA
they were able to come to LA you know
for three weeks or four weeks twice a
year they knew there was some meetings
that they would probably miss out on but
it was really important
for them to stay where they were at
until they had a career so it can be
done it is it is I would say it's gonna
be it's gonna diminish your chance of
somewhat I'm sorry significantly but
it's good to miss your chance of
somewhat it's gonna make things a little
more harder maybe take longer but then
again the trade-off for a lot of people
is I have a life here my kids go to
school I own a home I have a business
and I don't want to uproot everything so
it's it's a trade-off that people have
to make I would say if you can come to
LA I would I'd come here for the
development phase but I'd definitely
come here for the career launch phase
now once you've launched your career if
it's feature film writing you live
anywhere you know I did that for ten
years I could live anywhere in the world
I see a lot of writers who don't want to
be staffed on shows they just want to
sell original material and they'll sell
two or three scripts or pitches a year
and that's a very nice income and then
down the road if you do that enough
times one of those might get made and
that could be a very nice income so if
that's the case you have to come here
for pitching season maybe two months out
of the year I know people that are here
for two months out of the year you know
they rent an apartment for two months
and then they go back to New York where
they go back to Toronto they go back to
South Africa obviously if you want to be
staffed on the show you're gonna if you
get staffed on a show you need to live
where the room is you know and that's
usually in LA or sometimes New York but
usually LA so I would just say you don't
have to live in LA it is helpful it
might expedite the process it might make
it a little more likely might make it
easier so if you can if you're on the
fence I would absolutely come to LA but
if you have very strong reasons why you
want to stay put as long as you can be
here twice a year for three to four
weeks then you can do that and if
someone's here taking meetings and then
they have additional time yeah what are
some things they should be doing not
just I'm not not sightseeing wise but
like in terms of getting to know the
industry feeling the temperament yeah
whatever
so it's a great question
and the answer might might surprise some
people or not let me let me share a big
mistake that writers make I know I would
have made this I was just lucky so I
didn't have the opportunity to make it
so you write a script and let's say
you've really written an amazing
exceptional script and you'll you'll
know because people will want to meet
with you there's a big difference
between an agent or manager trying to
get someone to meet with you as opposed
to people calling the agent man you're
insane everyone's buzzing about this
script I finally looked at it I want to
meet them and the manager is like well
they're they're booked for the next
three weeks they're like I will I will
cancel a dinner I will cancel lunch like
they are moving their schedule to meet
you you'll feel it when you go in a room
it's really exciting and what's gonna
happen is like someone's gonna buy that
script and and but then there's a
there's a whole process for all the
deals to come through or someone's
buying the pitch and it's like it's it's
a done deal and then three months later
it isn't
it'll this happens all the time and Ikes
you know it'll go all the way the finish
line is a very last second for something
you can never before see your anticipate
done happen and it's now been three to
four months since that buzz from the
script and you were sure this was
landing a career and it suddenly doesn't
which is very common and that's when
your agent or manager says well where's
your next script and the problem is a
lot of writers they are not writing
another script because they are taking
all these meetings which is it's a
full-time thing because you know pitches
have take a lot of preparation and get
notes on the pitches people are reading
your script they're asking about the
first year they have some issue you're
doing a lot of creative work in
preparation for these meetings it's
really time-consuming and especially
let's say you live in LA you know you're
working your day job trying to support
yourself like it's exhausting and no one
really has time to do this and be
writing another script and they know
they're gonna launch it career but then
it doesn't happen and then the agent
manages where's your next script and you
don't have one
and it was really problematic for a lot
of reasons for most people when you know
you're gonna get a deal and it falls
through emotionally that's not always
the best time to be starting a new
project you know is not always our most
confident place secondly you've got to
get a script really quick or the
industry's gonna say you wrote this one
script it was amazing but you're slow I
mean and they're gonna forget about you
like that like that buzzes you got has a
shelf life and it's less than you
thought so ideally if everything falls
apart you have another script like in
three weeks and I don't mean to say
three weeks is the magic nut but you
want another amazing script soon and
keep this in mind most people don't get
hired on their first round of meetings
they get hired on their second or third
round of meetings because now they've
proven they're consistent they're not a
one-trick pony and they can do this
repeatedly because there are some people
who can write one great script but they
can't write multiple great scripts and I
have seen writers who go through this
round of meetings their project is
getting made if there's just not this
person attached and this attached and
it's a done deal and then it's not and
there's four months later and they're
demoralized and they can't bring
themselves to write because they feel
like that was the best script I could
write and it wasn't good enough and then
their agent her managers like where's
your next script and like I don't have
one and they're like when can you get me
one and it's like I don't know and then
you don't have an agent or manager so
when you're going out on those meetings
especially when it looks great
especially when like this is leading to
a career and nothing can derail it I
don't think you should be doing the site
scene I don't think you should be trying
to take the temperature of the industry
I think you should be taking meetings
and writing hope for the best prepare
for the worst and so if it doesn't
happen in this round of meetings you
have another great script soon
thereafter and if you repeat this
process you're going to get a career and
if you don't repeat this process then
you better be really lucky on that first
round of meetings the very first place I
went we're
scot-free and they bought my pitch so
that can happen the very first place you
walk in the second place the third place
gets a deal it can happen it happened
for me if it didn't happen for me and I
went through that round of meetings I
didn't have another script now would
have been demoralized and it would've
been really hard to write another script
and I don't know what would have
happened and I might have lost my agent
and I might have lost all that momentum
that doesn't mean you can't start over
again but you actually start over with a
strike against you cuz they're like oh
yeah you're a slow writer oh yeah you
had an agent but you lost an agent these
don't look good these are not good
things on your you know your industry
resume so when you're taking these round
of meetings it's so important that you
write and I would say forgive little for
people who live in LA if possible and I
know this isn't possible for everyone if
possible when you're going on that round
of meetings and you have a partner and
say you're married or in a serious
relationship see if you can't pre
negotiate that during that time you
don't have to work and they work and
support you and them or you've save
enough money because if possible and I
know for some people this is impossible
but if possible when you're going on
those round of meetings and be really
great if you didn't have to work and
make a living that you have two jobs
those meetings and your next script
you recall the meeting you had with
Ridley Scott like it was yesterday and I
will answer that but I'm gonna be
annoying and answer some I want to talk
about the mean I had before because I
think there's a teaching moment in here
so I had an idea for a movie and I
pitched it to my agent and she goes out
I think this is great let's take it out
to the marketplace and then she said
let's make a list of our dream places
that we want to sell it so she goes if
you could sell to anyone who would it be
and it was so heavy I thought like oh
yeah who would I sell it to and I said
Ridley Scott you can't laugh like okay
yeah we'll take it there and then when
they come well-well go down let's then
we'll go to places that actually could
so I go into really Scott and I pitched
with soo Williams who is a development
executive smart nicest woman and you
know this is really important when
you're pitching is you're trying to get
as much information so I was pitching
her this project and at some point I saw
her body language shift and I go it was
it's something off about that and she
goes really doesn't like these kind of
things I don't think I think this is
really exciting for him but not if it's
going down that road and like what kind
of things is really like and so she
started sharing things was so helpful so
we could kind of retool the pitch
together and so she was instrumental so
when you go someone you're pitching you
know you're trying to get as much
information from that person and it's a
real sometimes writers have ego and
they're like yeah I'm going in this
place and I'm pitching the little lowest
person on the totem pole oh that's great
because you get information about the
decision-maker
okay so sue Williams help me reformulate
the pitch in a way that would be a
better fit for Ridley so that was
amazing and that was I will forever be
grateful for her then I got brought in
to pitch to Mimi who was at the time
relays producing partner and this is a
long pitch this is a almost an hour
pitch it's like a 50-minute pitch this
is not a short pitch I always hate when
people say your pictures have to be this
amount of time there's no rules like
first of all when someone says you have
you have to do your pitch in ten minutes
people think that people will listen to
you for ten minutes they'll listen to
you as long as they're interested and if
they're not interested thirty seconds
they tune you out
and most pitches that sell are longer
pitches because people want to have the
confidence that this has been worked out
and what they're buying is legit anyway
it says a long pitch so I'm pitching the
Mimi and it can't be going worse she's
sitting back like this she's not making
an eye contact she looks in pain she
looks like this pitch is so bad that it
is making her go crazy and the only
reason I have a career is at the time I
wanted to be doing stand-up or improv so
I was pursuing that and an improv I was
learning that one of my problems my
weaknesses is when I thought things were
going well I was alive and animated but
when I thought things weren't going
about any thought Ian was into it my
fear of rejection run this through this
I would sort of back off and sort of
tune out of the scene I kind of let you
guys take it I would just sort of drop
out of the scene which is you don't do
that as an improviser so what I was
being taught is when you think things
are going terrible walk to the center of
the stage take focus and say something
and just stay in there stay alive don't
worry about people's judgments follow
your process so I'm pitching in after
about seven minutes I'm like she hates
me she hates this pitch she's never
gonna buy it she's in pain and that
voice says just do the short version and
get out of here this is painful for her
it's painful for you Ridley was never
gonna buy this pitch just get out of
here just wrap it up and go which I
would do is a stand-up terrible habit
but another voice said okay look you're
never going to be a writer as evidenced
by the pain you're causing this woman
maybe you could be a performer so use
this as a way of practicing your improv
skills stay engaged stay engaged that
that voice went through my head so I
stay engaged and I I just did the pitch
with gusto and focus and try not to look
too much at me and see how much pain she
was in and I finished and then there was
just silence I mean for silence and then
she stands up and she goes hmm I don't
get it
and then sue Williams said well what
don't you get she goes all of it then
she looked at me and she was like
something like maybe we'll be in touch
or just something and walked out and sue
didn't know what to say I don't know
to say and then I left and I drove home
and I called my agent and I'm like well
you were right Ridley's not gonna buy
this then sue calls me and I pick up the
phone you know and she's like hey when
you pitch with me you were really good
but when you pitched for me me and I
know where this was going she said you
were on fire
I mean even loved it now there's a
lesson in this which is don't try to
read the room because I've pitched to
people I've pitched the heads of studios
that laughed and loved it because they
when someone's hearing a pitch they're
trying to decide am I gonna buy this am
I gonna take this to my boss that's
could be stressful and I pitched her
studio once where he knew right away he
wasn't gonna buy it because they had a
similar idea and development so he just
relaxed and had fun with me we had a
great time but he already knew he wasn't
gonna buy it
I found out Mimi like only takes one or
two pitches to Ridley a year and when
she was hearing this pitch she was like
internally going oh my god this is
something really would really love and I
can't speak for her but I'm guessing
that maybe she was nervous because maybe
she was thinking do I really want to put
my career on the line with this guy like
I was a nobody I was in film school I
hadn't I was was like 23 and green as
they came and I think that she probably
hearing the pitch was having an internal
debate you know again I can't speak for
her but that's my guess so Seuss she was
like yeah I probably should have told
you she could be a little like that's
sort of her way she listens so don't
read people's like I've been in rooms
where people seem like they hated it and
sometimes they do and sometimes they
don't stay committed have integrity do
the pitch okay so to your question sorry
for the long window so I was told that
really wouldn't be back in town for a
month Mimi did have one big concern that
she wanted changed it was a hard
creative thing to figure out but I'm
like I have a month to figure it out few
days later I told you I got a phone call
here's what I didn't tell you I don't
drink much alcohol I'm just a
lightweight I'm the cheapest date ever
and the night before I was at some party
and I drank more than I'd ever drink in
my
life and it doesn't take much to get me
drunk I think that morning might have
been my first ever hangover or was the
worst ever hangover so when the phone
rang I hadn't showered it was I hadn't
shaven I was hungover it was my agent
and she said Ridley's in town and he
would like to hear the pitch he has an
hour here's a slot in an hour can you
hear the pitch and it takes 45 minutes
to get there to Beverly Hills from where
I was and so I said and it's not a good
idea but I said oh that's exciting
can we bump it up till 2:00 and there
was this long pause and I know my agent
was thinking why did I sign this guy and
she said so Cory Ridley's in town he has
a slot he'd like to hear your pitch in
an hour
and at least then I was like of course I
will be there in an hour
this kind of works out to my favor so I
quickly shave and shower and on the
drive drink coffee on the drive over I'm
just figuring out a solve that create a
problem what happened is I got there
with a second to spare and they dripped
me into the room with him I never had
the chance to get nervous I never had a
chance to psych myself out I was just on
pure adrenaline and Ridley was the
sweetest person ever he came in the room
you know and I started to like you know
it's an honor and it was like Blade
Runner and alien like I it was a literal
honor to be in a room with him let alone
the fact that he was gonna listen to me
he pitched a project and he just
immediately said like I you know were
just two creative people I want to hear
your idea you don't have to be great at
performing my staff loves it I just want
to hear like he went out of his way to
make me feel comfortable and that I
belong there because I did not feel like
I belonged in a room pitching to really
Scott and I was just on adrenaline with
no prep time the prep you know psyched
myself out and so I just started talking
and he was just he listened any and he
nodded and he was so receptive and he
was so loving and gentle I'll I'll never
forget that
and he was just amazing and then at the
end he asked the question he always
wanted here which is he said so who else
has heard this pitch and I said nobody
you're the first pitch your first play
well who else is going to hear this
pitch and I gave some of the places that
we had meeting set up and he looked at
his staff and then he turned to me and
he said who's your agent and I told him
Dan Karan's I see him
and he called my agent and he said I
want to take this off the market so that
was just like I I really thought I was
dreaming
and then I remember I was driving home
in my like cruddy little car and I will
Flynn the dogs car club it because you
had to use your feet to stop it
thumbskull no money car and I was
driving on the 405 and I started shaking
I just was shaking I had a pullover and
the thought that went through my head
wasn't that I just launched my career it
wasn't that I just sold the thought that
went through my head was I just met
Ridley Scott so nerdy I was just and not
only that once the deal was consummated
they said we want you on the next plane
to London so that Ridley and his team
will develop the structure with you and
they meant the literal next plane to
London so my wife and I my girlfriend at
the time now wife Rebecca we were like
she's like I'll help you pack because I
don't know how to pack and I'm like
great and she's getting all my clothes
where's your suitcase I'm like what I
don't have oh you know so we ran to like
Target and bought a suitcase and
everything and then they flew me
first-class and I didn't know
first-class exists I didn't know what
first-class was I did grew up with no
money so they kept bringing me like food
and wine and I was like no no no like I
was thinking I can't afford this you
know like I can't afford I don't want to
pay for all this when I land and then in
some point in London someone said no in
first-class it's all included on the way
back I was like more food but yes rid
leave just I mean he treated me
throughout the entire process and he
called me when they weren't gonna make
it and he explained why which he didn't
have to do
throughout the entire process he treated
me like a like a writer who belonged to
be there and someone that he wanted he
wanted to hear my opinions he didn't
want me just to defer to him I mean it
was amazing I forever be grateful for
that he spoiled me because at some point
I was like well I thought everyone now
that's how the we I'd worked for some of
the best people in the business I saw
they treat writers and I've worked with
people who don't treat writers that way
so when you pulled over on the 405 do
you remember was there a song playing on
the radio or I don't I just write think
I remember I was gonna crash that's a
good gosh I don't remember I just kept
thinking I saw I came home and my
girlfriend was like so and I'm like I
meant really Scott and she's like I know
you meant Ridley Scott though oh yeah he
bought he bought it I was just I was
just a little film scold nerd who was
excited to me Ridley Scott
we took a break for a moment an
off-camera you said something about
character and dialogue and how you help
your students and how in some ways a lot
of the they're the same thing in some
ways yeah so and I talked about this
sort of more globally in the creative
integration video that people can go
back that I did it for you guys a couple
years ago I'll I'll I'll give a little
more specific so there's a little more
specifics on the intuitive training and
and there'll be a practical test that
people can take at the end to see where
they're at service so when I work with
someone especially someone who needs to
improve on their characters and dialogue
and I'm going to short stroke this a
little bit because you can go back to
the creative integration video for a
full explanation of the conceptual me
intuitive but often that the conceptual
brain is very focused on what other
people think fear of rejection want it
to be good and it's controlling and that
can be helpful and and there's certainly
when we're doing story designing we
wanted design stories don't even really
engaging other people we want to be
aware of how people are seeing our
scripts so the conceptual brain is a
really important part in this but the
intuitive brain is where our
authenticity comes from our emotional
authenticity and the intuitive brain
doesn't have a past present or a future
just hasn't now and so the first part of
what I'm working with someone to get
them better at characters and or
dialogue the first thing is to train
them through practic ated practice to
build to turn off the conceptual brain
and just work from a pure intuitive
space and the metaphor I would give them
is imagine it sounds crazy but you ride
your horse to work so that's how you get
to work and you have to get to work in
half an hour and your horse likes to
wander and wants to go grazing and look
at waterfalls but you have to control
the horse because you got to get to work
and you make sure that your horse gets
you to work in half an hour and this
metaphor you the writer or the
conceptual brain
and the horse is the intuitive part of
us and so the first thing is to release
and surrender control to the horse and
let the horse go wherever the horse
wants to go and don't control it and
don't even judge it it's almost like you
just get off the horse and this you know
for this day the horse can do whatever
it wants and so training people and this
this is the hardest part of the training
and it can take weeks it can take a
month or two but it's literally learning
how to just get a prompt and just
immediately start writing without any
ideas of story without any control
without any editing it's just letting
that intuitive instinct take over and
just go wherever it goes and it's like
it's like a dream in that it doesn't
have to be logical it doesn't have to be
interesting it just has to be authentic
and real and really stressed
non-performance writing
no one's gonna read this so to warm up
by people do journaling they'll journal
for 15 or 20 minutes because when we're
journaling especially if no one reads
our journals what do we navigate toward
we're not trying to be a good writer or
an interesting writer we're just trying
to navigate towards the truth you know
trying to find our truth or exploring a
topic or just trying to maybe just
writing about how we feel and that's
non-performance writing you know as
opposed to when we fire up final draft
or whatever software we use it's like
I'm gonna write something and people are
gonna read it and they're gonna judge it
and they're by by default they're gonna
judge me or certainly feels that way
so this first level of training is
learning how to turn off the conceptual
brain and literally it's like
trance-like writing you you eventually
get to the place where you could do this
for 20 minutes 30 minutes 45 minutes and
when you're done you don't even remember
what you wrote it's just completely
authentic intuitive lead writing so
that's the first step I mean that's not
getting you to great characters in
dialog but that's the first step on the
journey would to use another metaphor I
would say it's like if I was teaching
someone yoga
but they couldn't they were so non
limber they couldn't even get down to
the floor this first phase is just
getting down to the floor it's not
actual yoga but it's getting some ones
they can get down to the floor so that's
the first phase and it's the hardest
phase for most writers so when they can
get to a point where they can write no
judging no editing completely intuitive
surrender control of the horse and just
trance-like writing then we go to the
second phase and the second phase is I'm
going to teach them how to write from a
really really provocative emotional
feeling an autobiographical event like
the best most one you know when their
child was born or when their father died
I mean we're talking like primal moments
and I'm gonna train them how to write in
a way where they let the feeling that
they're feeling this emotion leave the
writing and they're gonna do it to the
point and keep practicing until myself
or someone else when they read these
pages they can feel what the writer felt
so they can they can it's a now and
energy transference and emotional
transference to be able to really engage
us with characters and dialogue you're
gonna have to be able to do this now
there are people listening to this who
don't need any training to do this they
are very deep intuitive's they they
absolutely can do this right now without
any training but there are people that
need structured training to get to this
point where they can let go of their
control ego-mind work from a pure
intuitive space and write in a way where
people can feel what they feel then we
go to phase three and in phase three
there's techniques to start to discover
actual characters and you interview
these characters you spend time with
these characters and there's a bunch of
play exercises till the character will
take over and will happen is you can
start writing and you put the character
in some situation and they just do what
they would do and they just say what
they would say and they are driving it
you're not you have no agenda now maybe
what the character is doing or saying is
particularly interesting might not make
for a great story but the character is
doing what they do in saying what they
would say then the next phase is
learning how to write where what the
character is feeling the reader can feel
so now we can emotionally bond and
connect with the character we can feel
what they're feeling that's really
powerful and again some writers
naturally do this and some writers
naturally don't do anything close this
but through this training they can get
there then the next phase is we will
find another character that they spend
time do this training with so they'll
eventually have two characters that they
always know what that character would do
they always know what that character
would say and they have they have
surrender control to the characters
we'll put the characters in a certain
situation a certain basic conflict and
they very slowly will go back and forth
writing it from inside each character so
this character would do that well with
this character do whoa a dis character's
response and now the characters are
creating what happens now again maybe
what's happening is really compelling
and riveting maybe it's not maybe it's
really boring it doesn't matter it's the
characters doing what the characters
would do in interaction with each other
and so ultimately and here's something
that someone can do right now if they
want to test their ability this is where
I would say someone comes out the other
end
earning their intuitive merit badge so
to speak which is so ultimately where we
want to get to is organic story
structure which is a it's a term that's
used a lot but not often really
understood so the way I would define it
is organic means everything the
characters do it feels like they would
really do it everything the character
says feels like they would really say it
there's never a moment where you see the
hand of the writer there's never a
moment where fills in organics there's
never a moment where a character is
doing a preordained plot point or a
character's doing something or saying
something because the writer wanted them
to do they're saying this to drive the
story forward a certain way that's or
Organic story structure means everything
that's happening is the most compelling
choice from a story point of view and
the story keeps getting more and more
interesting it's really hard for writers
to do both to do organic story structure
because in the best scripts the the
scripts that can change your writers
life you read the script and you never
see a hand never see the hand the writer
it never feels inorganic it just feels
like these characters these are real
people they all have a unique voice
they're all saying what they would say
they're all doing what they would do and
it's never boring it is just captivating
ly interesting it gets more and more
interesting that's the Holy Grail when a
writer can do that they are the needle
in the haystack that the industry is
looking for everyone want to meet that
writer and work with that writer so the
first step I would tell people and this
is what we're talking about this
question is the organic so let's take
story structure off the table excuse me
so with organic what I would tell
someone is this is how we know you've
successfully come you successfully come
through the end of this training or
sometimes writers will come to me and
I'm like you seem like you have really
strong intuitive skill sets maybe you
don't need to do this training let's
test where you're at so this is what I
would have them do I would have them
take two or three characters that they
know they love these characters these
characters have unique voices they know
exactly what these characters would do
or say and we're going to put them into
a conflict a situation and they're gonna
write it doesn't it's not going to be a
full scripts not going to be a whole
pilot or a feature we don't need to do
that let's say 25 pages and what I task
the writer with doing is just let the
characters do whatever they would do and
say whatever they would say don't worry
if it's interesting don't worry about
you know context and it being funny or
dramatic it could be boring it just has
to be completely organic and when you're
done we're gonna take these 25 pages and
we're gonna give it to five or six
people that you trust and you're gonna
give each of them a red marker and
you're going to explain
you did and you're gonna say I know this
sounds crazy but I don't care if what
you're reading is interesting I don't
care if it's boring I don't care if it's
illogical all I care about is it 100%
organic do all the characters speak with
the unique voice do the characters it
all the time feel like they're doing
what they would really do saying what
they would really say if there's ever a
moment where you're like I'm not sure I
believe the character would have said
that I don't know if the character was
motivated to say that or felt little
force that they did that or felt like
you were controlling or any of that
market circle with red put a red mark on
it it's okay again if it's completely
boring we're going for organic and if
you get the seven drops back without any
red lines you have your intuitive merit
badge which means you are capable of
organic now you're not going to take
those 25 pages and go out to the
marketplace with it but you can do
organic then and this is this would be a
longer conversation for another day then
you have to train yourself on story
structure and then it's a matter of
putting the two together to have organic
story structure but in terms of
character and dialogue going through
those stages and coming out where you
can be fully organic is a huge move
forward because now when someone reads
your script they're gonna feel like
these are real people and the dialogue
is gonna feel real and these characters
are going to have emotional in our lives
and we're going to believe each of the
characters that's the first part then
when you can do that integrated with
story design with story structure then
you get to those magical scripts where
everything is organic and authentic and
it is the story is absolutely grabs our
attention holds our attention and
delivers us somewhere that exceeds our
expectations and I have seen the
challenge that a lot of people make is
they try to learn to do all of that at
once and it's really difficult it's like
you know trying to Bowl when you have
that ten four split the two pins are as
far apart and if you tried it with one
ball knocked both pins down usually
so what I trained people to do is just
focus on organic just be able to nail
that then sort of the peak in how I
train writers and the workshops will
also train people to just do story
structure with like puppets it can be
inorganic where you know how to design
the most compelling story even if it's
completely inorganic and feels like
you're controlling the characters that's
okay we're not going to take that and
show it to anyone in the industry this
is all training but then when you can do
story structure and then you can do
organic or you can do organic and then
you can do story structure then I can
teach you how to put the two together
where they integrate so I always teach
these separately three proven techniques
for overcoming procrastination to get
the work done yeah I mean obviously it's
about realizing that everyone starts out
with inherent strengths weaknesses and
blind spots and it's about turning blind
spots and weaknesses and then
relentlessly attacking weaknesses turn
them into strands to grow or Talent but
all the town in the role without
dedication probably won't be enough so
no matter how talented a writer is it's
so important that they consistently work
and they put the time and energy and a
lot of writers deal procrastination and
I I get writers sent to me who deal with
procrastination now you know if I was
working as a writer I would really want
to try to find out why they're
procrastinating what it is they're
avoiding what their fear what their
triggers are so it is a very
personalized conversation but I can
share three techniques that work for a
lot of people maybe and so hopefully
your viewers at least one of these
things might be helpful for them and I'd
suggest trying all three if none of them
work for you try to find some other
things but there's a good chance that
any at least one of the things might
help so here's the first thing that I
suggest trying now and I call it
breaking the glass and so there's a tale
of a know of a Zen master and he has his
disciples and he has the most beautiful
delicate wineglass ever I mean it makes
people cry it's so beautiful but like
any wind it witch
and he's passing it around to people to
be in the moment with this amazing glass
and this one disciple doesn't want to
touch it because he's so afraid right
that he would break it and any and the
disciple turns to the Zen master and he
goes aren't you afraid that you're gonna
accidentally break this thing of beauty
and the Zen master says in my mind it's
already broken and so how this applies
is so when a writer procrastinates
almost always they're trying to avoid
doing something because there's a fear
or something they're afraid of
that's generally why we procrastinate
and so what I will do with a writer is
ask them so let's say they're per
casting finishing the script or starting
the script or Oh what are you afraid of
let's say you finish the scrub and and
you can say rational fears and
irrational fears but what are you afraid
of you know it's different for different
writers it might be you know the really
Scott deal when I wrote metropolis that
was my first ever script and so if it
went in and they didn't think it was
very good I probably would never get
another job offer because anyone who's
gonna hire me is gonna call Ridley and
say how was metropolis and if they're
like yeah that's it so I had a real fear
that this script wasn't good enough I
would never get another job my agent
would drop me I was literally afraid
that my golfin would leave me and I
would become homeless and live on the
streets eating garbage had all these
fears now some of those are rational and
some are irrational my girlfriend loved
me you know she married me she was never
gonna leave me because I wrote a bad
script and I wasn't gonna all my friends
weren't gonna abandon me but there were
rational fears it could have ended my
career and my agent could have dropped
me those are absolutely rational fears
so first thing is like write down
everything you're afraid of and have fun
with the irrational fears because when
you write them all down the irrational
fear is usually lose their power and you
can say this isn't going to happen
this is just some crazy thing in my head
this isn't gonna happen this could
happen even if I thought it was unlikely
my agent
drop me it's still possible so that is a
what I would say a rational fear so pick
the worst rational fear let's say for
argument's sake the worst rational fear
is my agent would draw me so what we
often do is humans is we want to avoid
pain we want to avoid our fear and so we
want to run away from it
and that is what often causes
procrastination so the breaking of the
glass is instead of being afraid that
you're gonna break the glass run to it
in your mind say the glass was already
broken so let's say the worst thing for
me is my agents going to drop me
so what the exercise is I sit down and I
I really use my imagination to pretend
that I've written the script Ridley
hates it and my agent is dropping me I
would literally write out the phone
conversation of what I think she would
say and what I would say try to be very
realistic how I think this would happen
and what I'm looking to do is to fully
experience it happening I mean you
should feel terrible you should feel
like you should really believe your
agent has just dropped you or whatever
it is that your worst fear is you should
experience it and then you feel terrible
take a couple deep breaths and then
write what would I do in that situation
what would really happen and I realized
in that situation I would learn from my
mistakes
I would write another script I would try
to get better I would try to get another
agent there's no guarantees that I would
but I wouldn't when wouldn't be the end
of me and I still would be in this
wonderful relationship have all my
friends if I had to those other things I
could do to make a living and I realized
like it's not as bad as I was imagining
in and it takes the power away from that
fear and also what I see a lot in
writers is when they do that they're
like you know what if I do write this
script and it ultimately fails I want to
go down swinging I want to write the
script that I would write I want to
follow mine things I remember an agent
told me that ones which is the worst
feeling is when you don't listen to your
instincts and you fail if you listen to
your instincts
and it ends up failing you can sleep at
night and you can learn from that so the
breaking of the glasses imagine your
career is over or somebody's like the
greatest thing is I'd write the script
and it wouldn't succeed and I would I
would quit writing okay so imagine that
imagine you wrote the script and it
failed would you really quit right and
if you did what would happen and or
would you not quit would you write no
and experience the worst thing come
through the other end and realize it's
not as bad as I thought and I'm gonna be
okay and then you're not as afraid of
that anymore and it diminishes the fear
even a little bit and if you could
diminish the fear a little bit that
might be all you need
to get back on track and right now I've
worked with writers with with chronic
procrastination issues and they
literally every day as part of their
practice they'll do this exercise for 20
minutes every day before they start
writing that's pretty hardcore most the
people they'll do it two or three days
and then they get going on the script
and then they'll just use this exercise
when they need to when they're really
stuck and fearful they'll use this
exercise so that's one thing that
writers can try and it doesn't work for
everybody but it it has worked for far
more writers than it hasn't and
sometimes it just helps a little bit and
that's all you need but sometimes it
helps it profoundly helps the writer so
takes 20 minutes to try it see what
happens so that's one one thing that
someone can do here's a second thing
that someone can do who suffers a lot
with procrastination and this one has
worked for almost everybody this has a
very high batting average so one of the
things in addition to why are you
procrastinating I'm always interested
when I talk to a writer what do you do
when you are procrastinating what do you
do besides writing and you get and very
interesting bizarre range of answers you
know from watching TV to playing video
games to things I don't want to talk
about in this interview and you know
lots of different cleaning obsessively
cleaning the house
whatever okay so what I the exercise how
I'll train this rider is okay so I want
you to like list out different things
that you could be writing not scripts
nothing with stakes that would be really
really fun I'm really engaging you know
some people they like write really angry
letters to people in their lives that
they're not going to send or I had
someone who's like I've always wanted to
be a stand-up I don't think I'm funny
but I would love to write jokes I had
someone she was in France and she was
I've always wanted to write an opera
just for like the hell of it I've had I
had someone say I've always wanted to
write a porno film I just think that
would be so much fun why not write so
you make a list of things that and and
these are obviously going to be things
probably that you would never think
you're gonna make a living doing well
you know writing angry letters to your
parents or people that wronged you
you're probably not gonna make a living
doing that so then what happens is you
have your script and you're supposed to
be writing your script you have time set
aside this two-hour block your writing
my script and you're not writing then
what you're going to do when you
procrastinate is one of these things so
you're gonna be writing your opera
you're gonna be writing your porno film
you're right angry letters or forgiving
letters or whatever it is because here's
the thing when someone's at the keyboard
writing it's so much easier to slip back
into the script so what I'm training
people to do is use writing as their per
cap as their procrastination tool from
writing so instead of writing so you're
not writing so instead of watching video
games or cleaning or whatever it is
you're doing you're not writing so
instead you're writing and what happens
is it's so much easier for them to just
slip back into writing so that can be a
really effective tool and I found that
that works for a large number of people
so take that out for a spin and see what
happens maybe that can be helpful so a
third and final tool and I
say this is one I need to get to there's
a little bit of breaking the glass in
case of an emergency so if it's a really
really hard hard case to solve
that the breaking the glass of running
applet you're afraid of as opposed to
running away and experiencing and coming
out the other end and or using writing
as a procrastination tool they're not
working so this is like okay we got to
do something hardcore for you then I use
the exercise of breaking the routine and
so what I do is I say I want you to set
up a space where you write you maybe
already have one ideally a separate room
not everyone can do that but if you have
a room where you work and you can
literally have a room with the door like
an office or a spare bedroom or some
part of the house it could even be a
closet I would people like clean out a
closet and use a closet because they're
in an apartment but you you don't have
to have the door but it's great if you
have a door and when you go in this
physical space and shut the door that's
your writing space and the rule is that
when you're in your writing space you
have to be writing you you finger is
happy moving across the keyboard and at
the moment that stops happening you must
get up and leave that room because that
is a writing room it is not an on
writing room it is not a procrastination
room now when you leave the room you are
going to leave for five minutes and only
five minutes and I'll say why in a
moment and I want you to do something in
those five minutes that can help try to
get you back into a writing space so
maybe it is maybe you do go write
something but not in that room somewhere
else or some people play the guitar some
people journal some people just do a
fast walk around the place
some people might meditate Yoga
experiment with things that help get you
out of your fear the help center you
back into a calm centered space five
minutes on a timer you can't take more
than five minutes because the part of
you that is trying to there's a part of
you that doesn't want you to write you
have to understand that there's a you
know we have this like lizard brain
structure and we have a part of us that
tries to prevent
from suffering like if you put your hand
on a hot stove you pull it away and that
part of us doesn't distinguish between
physical pain and emotional pain so I
remember when I was in high school hair
fighter girls and I remember being at
the dance I'm like I'm gonna ask that
girl to dance with me and I'm walking
over there and my lizard brains like
don't do it don't do it don't do it
everyone's watching you not true and
she's going to say no maybe and it's
gonna everyone's gonna ridicule you and
your whole life you're gonna be known as
the guy that got turned down by Jenny
don't ask her and it was all that like
my heart beat the drum the
fight-or-flight mechanism was going off
and it was terrifying that's why there's
so much alcohol with the mating ritual
because the alcohol can calm that down
so there's a part of us that doesn't
want us to right because if we right we
can fail and we can be rejected and that
really hurts and that can feel really
bad and our survival mechanism might
want to stop us from that so the reason
we only go do something for five minutes
is if it's longer than the part of us
that doesn't want us the right goes oh I
procrastinate you leave the writing room
for a long period of time I have power
over you know five minutes and then you
go back and you write now let's say you
go back and you you get up you leave
that room and you something for five
minutes could be the same thing and you
go back in the rule is you're never not
writing in that space that's the writing
space you're just like they say
insomniac so if you're having trouble
sleeping you should get out of bed and
you shouldn't stay in bed you don't want
a muscle memory train yourself that you
can stay in bed and not sleep you're not
going to you're you only write in that
room and when you go in that room I mean
literally feed off to just force your
fingers to go across the keyboard it and
do nonsense because at least that is the
motion of writing and then just try to
write and if you only write for like 20
seconds and then you like freeze up and
you procrastinate you get up for five
minutes and I have this is really
hardcore cases but I'll have people that
for weeks on end they're in that room
for 20 seconds a minute two minutes and
then they keep doing the five minutes
and if you were to watch them they're
constantly leaving the room for five
minutes playing their guitar
going back in that room at some point
they get so fed up with leaving that
room and here's the other thing in real
life if you have someone who keeps
coming into your workplace when you're
writing and saying you shouldn't be
writing this isn't any good you're no
good yeah this could fail this isn't
safe and they have power over you if
every time they show up you leave and
you don't listen to them you just walk
out over time they're gonna stop showing
up so that's breaking the routine you
just always leave that room and do
something for five minutes that can help
calm you and Center you then you go back
in that room and some people don't do
that for a week and then they're able to
write for five or ten minutes and then
they start to procrastinate and then
they it becomes a muscle and then at
some point they can't remember that it
was over
procrastination was ever a problem for
them I was i really suggest doing the
break the glass exercise and the making
writing your procrastination tool before
you do this because those are quicker
and in the majority of cases they will
do the trick
but if they don't this is a more
hardcore tool that you can try and so
far I've never worked with anyone that
some combination of this didn't didn't
work it's not to say that someone
listening to this will try all three and
it won't work but I think most people
who are listening to this if they
struggle with procrastination it's I
hope I hope that at least one of these
or some combination will do the trick
because I used to procrastinate and I
hated it it's like in the day I feel so
exhausted from not like the energy of
not working and and resisting something
oh it's just it's so life draining it's
terrible and I know people that get into
the habit of that and that's just it
becomes habitual exercise for them so
these are ways that you can get out of
that habit so hopefully anyone is
suffering that way one of these will
help